Good
morning, Minto!
What do you say besides good morning, Minto?
That's all I say.
Good morning, Minto!
What if it's not the morning?
It's morning somewhere.
Good afternoon, Minto!
Yeah!
Yay!
It's always the quiz.
The VTuber sayings quiz at the start of any collab.
I know, right?
What do you say?
What do you do?
We're here, we're green, and we're playing Resident Evil 6.
Yes, and I think we both have no idea what this game is.
Somehow, I've wanted to play the co-op Resident Evils, though.
Me too, me too.
Yeah, I've been wanting to play.
But you said you've played 7 and... 7 and... Yeah, and 8.
8.
Yeah.
Or at least I'm familiar with 8.
But I think the older ones are super different.
We got... We got Leon here.
Yeah.
I honestly... Have you played Silent Hill?
Mm-hmm.
I honestly thought that Leon was... James.
James was Leon.
I think... I think that would insult some people.
I think some people are gonna get, like, triggered by that.
But... But... We don't have to pit two...
Two goats against each other, right?
Wait, did you play Silent Hill?
I played the remake of Silent Hill 2.
We're thinking... What?
James is the goat?
Wait, why not?
He...
I don't know.
I like the ending.
Well, have you played it?
Can I spoil it?
I played... I didn't play the remake.
I played the original.
Maybe it's a different experience.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I like the ending where he...
He drives into the lake to be with his beloved in the afterlife forever.
Yeah.
I think that makes him pretty...
Pretty good.
I mean...
I'm understanding your...
Your romantic interests.
Yeah.
I like it tragic and toxic.
Well, you know...
I get that.
If she can't be happy...
She shouldn't be happy either.
Yeah.
You know, I think you're changing my perspective a little bit.
I...
Oh yeah.
Well, so I don't know about Leon.
I don't know.
I think Leon is like a good guy.
I think he's like...
Right?
Like...
Normal guy.
So he wouldn't...
Hallucinate a hot lady with the same face as his wife?
Probably not.
For him to...
Have an affair with.
Leon is textbook good guy according to Chai.
Oh, he's a himbo.
Okay.
I like that.
I like that too.
You know, Nimi...
If you really like toxic...
I'm just gonna say it right now.
Yeah?
You should play...
You should play Metal Gear.
Really?
Is it toxic?
Oh...
Oh, man.
Oh, boy.
Yeah.
Actually...
It's on my list to play.
Wait, actually?
Yeah, I want to...
I mean, there's a lot of games.
I need to...
I'm gonna play it at some point.
For sure.
You heard it here first, folks.
I'll try to bump it up in my list.
No, no.
You don't have to.
Get through what you want first.
I'm just saying...
I feel like I'm obligated...
To say...
To bring it up at least once, you know?
Yeah, the Metal Gear Solid ambassador.
My unofficial title, yeah.
I wanted to play it.
It's like...
I feel...
It was like...
Improperly advertised to me.
I thought it was like...
Cool guy...
Military game.
But it's not at all.
Not...
What is it?
It's like...
Stealth.
You're in a box.
That's what I know about Metal Gear.
It's like...
Super...
Like...
It's super like...
Interpersonal relationships.
Oh.
And like...
How...
Do you get to choose things?
Or do you just watch?
You just watch.
It's a movie.
That's...
That's good.
I like a movie game.
I like to sit.
Watch.
The fourth game has a cutscene that's over an hour long.
Real movie game.
Yeah.
I'll pull it out for when I don't feel like streaming.
I just feel like watching.
And then you've played Hitman before.
So you can like...
Use your...
Hitman...
Uh...
Special...
T.
Is it similar?
I guess...
Hitman's also like stealth...
Game.
Yeah.
Actually, I've never played Hitman.
It's funny.
I was thinking about starting the Hitman series.
And then...
The same week...
You played it.
And I was like...
Whoa.
You should play it.
That's my Oshii.
She's got the same brain as me.
It's good.
But I've never played the story though.
Oh.
You're just in it for the thrill.
I think I...
I'm talking people.
There's a roguelite mode.
Where you can play it infinitely.
And it's...
What?
Me, that's...
That's everything.
What?
That sounds so fun.
It's very fun.
And it's pretty hard.
It's very hard.
Oh.
But...
What?
Now that I've played it...
Because...
The story mode...
In comparison...
Feels kind of like...
On rails.
You know?
The story mode is very good.
You should probably play it...
First.
Don't be like me.
Otherwise...
You'll feel like...
You put the training wheels back on.
Oh.
I see.
Yeah.
I get it.
You're like too...
You're far beyond...
What the story mode offers.
Even though it's still good.
She's a professional, everybody.
I'm not.
I haven't...
You...
You need to...
If to be a professional...
You have to get the bloody suit.
Which is your trophy...
For beating hardcore freelancer.
And I don't have it.
Wait.
Do like...
People freak out.
They're like...
Why is this guy covered in blood?
Or is it just like...
No.
They don't care.
It's cosmetic.
Same as if you dress as a clown.
They don't care.
It's pretty great.
You can wear whatever you want.
You can dress up.
Age of 47.
And it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
I thought that you had like...
Disguises and stuff.
Well, there are disguises.
But what you start with...
They don't care.
Does he get hair?
He could get a wig...
In the clown outfit.
A rainbow.
A rainbow clown wig.
I don't know if he has any hair...
Other than that though.
I don't think he should have hair.
I don't think so either.
He's better bald.
It would feel weird.
We can both be bald.
Unkeen.
My hotkeys never work.
A collab.
Where's my bald hotkey?
Oh no.
You're...
It's breezy.
How come I do...
Do you...
I use my stream deck.
Are you a pro?
Yeah, but...
Mine never works...
When I'm in a collab.
Really?
Wait, wait.
Isn't some on this screen?
Oh, it is.
Never mind.
It works.
Beautiful.
We're ready to Hitman.
We are.
I wish Hitman had multiplayer.
We're so good.
Bomb.
Oh my gosh, so shiny.
Your head.
Oh, you too.
It's like...
Like two cubals.
Like a carton of eggs.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
It really does look like we're two little eggs.
Wait.
If I...
Hold on.
I'm going to put us down a little bit.
So you only see the top of our...
Wow.
I feel like my head's way bigger than yours.
I'm feeling self-conscious.
You have the bigger brain.
That's why.
I'm not.
You're just really, really smart.
No.
Oh my goodness.
It's all just like...
Toxic vampire romance in my brain.
That's what it's filled with.
To the brim.
From...
From what medium?
I mean, of course, it started with Twilight.
But...
You know.
Well, lately I've been playing...
The Witcher.
Oh, yeah.
I saw it.
You'll see.
Yeah, and there's...
There's vampires in there.
You can write so much fan fiction about those vampires.
Vampires.
Should we...
Should we get into this game?
I guess we should probably.
We put our hair back on.
I like how yours like flies away.
It does.
I can like...
I can like tease it.
I'm like...
Yours is so good though.
Takes my ears off too.
I know.
The mutilation.
Okay, let me make the room then.
We tried doing this earlier, you guys.
And...
I picked Ada because I thought...
Nimi would be able to pick someone else.
But we...
Wait, it says continue.
Uh-oh, wait.
Uh-oh.
We locked in.
Let me just do the chapter select and we'll start.
Okay.
Okay, here...
Wait.
This is...
What's the prelude?
I think that's the tutorial that we did.
Yes.
We did the tutorial.
So I guess I will be...
Leon.
Okay.
And you might be...
Helena.
Oh, you are!
My favorite Nike Nike Nike romance song.
Wait a second.
Wait.
Go back.
Did it let me do...
Multiplayer?
Wait.
I think...
I hope so.
Let me in.
Oh, here we...
Uh...
Yes.
Here we go.
Okay.
Difficulty normal.
Screen single.
So each of us have our own POV.
Oh, do you want to be Leon?
I could be Helena if you want.
I want to be Leon.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
All right.
I think this is all...
Guys, what is the attack reaction?
Is that like QTEs?
The QTEs are so funny to me.
I know!
In this game.
It's like you're falling out of a helicopter...
And they're like...
Spin the right stick around in a circle.
We're in no rush here.
Peak gameplay.
I love the QTEs.
Oh, oh, it's friendly fire.
Oh, wait.
Um, maybe we don't want friendly fire.
Yeah, maybe, maybe not.
Okay.
Just kidding.
Then, what's agent hunt settings?
I don't, it won't even let me change that.
I don't even know.
I don't know.
Um, okay.
Start game.
And then, I invite you.
Yes.
I invite you.
Some people said that this game is bad.
I've heard that too.
Is it really?
Where is it?
Where is the peak?
Oh, I failed to join your game session.
Oh, don't!
Uh-oh.
Let me redo.
Um, I've heard that it's like Kuso game.
Well, I love Kuso game.
Yeah, me too.
So, I think it's fine.
Yeah.
We're in.
Are we in?
Are you in?
Did you make it?
I'm loading.
Are you in tall?
Oh, I'm in!
There's a...
Yes!
Cut scene!
Bio-organic weapons are a global threat.
Start working with the rest of the world.
Raccoon City.
Is this like a recap of the last game?
Is the audio doubled for you too?
It's doubled for you?
Oh, wait.
I think it was for cinematic effects.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Mr. President!
Oh, it's that scene.
It was that famous image.
I don't know it.
I need to catch up on my lore.
The zombie looking at the screen like that?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Mr. President!
He's still hesitating.
Like, oh, maybe he's still in there.
Yeah.
Maybe we can fix him still.
I think the, you know, the...
The tree bark skin is a dead giveaway.
He's not coming back.
Or maybe he's just like, I don't want to go to jail for killing the president.
I don't know if they're going to pardon me just because he's a zombie.
Who would pardon?
That's true.
You killed the president!
What are you talking about?
Tolong's Cathedral.
I'll explain everything there, Agent Kennedy.
Wait, are we a president too?
No, we're...
Agent Kennedy?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, are we related?
That's why we murdered the president so we could take our rightful throne.
Yeah, yeah.
That's how it works.
I hate to rush introductions, but I need a report on this situation.
Trial by combat.
I killed the president.
Oh my god!
He had already been infected by the time we found him.
He's not all got you.
Leon...
Leon did what he had to.
He saved my life.
Does that make it okay?
Yeah.
Bro, who is this girl?
I mean, I know he was a zombie.
The virus has already spread three miles past the camera's perimeter, and it's not going down.
I'm like, to hurry?
Not before we check out Taluk's cathedral.
Agent Kennedy's got a lead that might tell us who's responsible for this.
Leon, is that true?
She's like, just say yes.
I think I might have something.
I'm not about to say this.
Leon, Leon, yeah.
I got a lead.
You will if you come with me.
Are they an item?
Hot stuff.
No.
No?
Oh.
Wait, is this Helena?
Yeah, yeah, you're Helena.
Leon only cares about Ada.
Oh, no.
Oh.
She was in a submarine, you guys.
We saw a nice little glimpse of her.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
It's hard to explain.
He says you're in the name of the cathedral.
You may not believe me.
Do I look like a Nimmy?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I've been watching Game of Thrones, and all I can see is that he looks kind of like Jamie Lannister.
I've never seen Game of Thrones, but I believe you.
It's...
I like it too much, possibly.
Are you going to finish it?
Apparently, it gets really bad.
Yeah, I was going to say...
I haven't finished it yet.
I was going to say, so I feel like I've heard some people are...
You're going to tell me everything once we get to the cathedral.
Stop talking, Leon.
Deal.
Hey, don't tell me to shut up.
But yeah, I've heard some people say that they just don't finish the series because they know it gets bad.
Well, that's my plan.
Because the books end.
There's no ending.
My thing just had like a...
Oh, space.
Are you using mouse and keyboard?
Yeah, I'm being...
I'm...
You're ready to game.
I am...
Wait, but there was like a little investigation icon.
Where did it go?
I clicked it.
Oh, you did.
You just said the powers out.
Oh, that's it.
I don't know why you didn't see ya.
Okay.
We're being nice and secret.
We're...
We're being nice and slow and steady.
Mm-hmm.
I don't know what we're doing.
We're going to the cathedral, baby.
Okay.
Ivy University.
Is that where we're at?
Why are we here?
Is this where the pres...
Why is the president at the university?
Oh, suddenly I can run.
Well, did it ever say he was the president of the United States?
Maybe he is just the president of this university.
That's true.
Whoa, this place is fancy.
Yeah, it is.
Is there really a zombie outbreak?
It's kind of dangerous to leave those candles on.
That's what I always think about.
One time I left a candle on all night and I woke up...
You too?
I've done that before.
I can't believe this is happening again.
I have like a candle warmer sometimes too that I use.
And I'll like go on walks and come back and be like, oh, it smells so nice in here.
That was my thought when I woke up the next day and walked out into the living room.
Oh, it smells so good in here.
Oh, wait.
I did it just the other day so now I'm thinking about...
Did you?
Well, the warmer is not as dangerous.
Yeah, probably.
President!
Only one way to find out.
Let's go.
Oh, we're running?
Oh, now we're fast.
Follow the shadow.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Why is it a...
These tables are huge.
They are.
We just...
We're like hobbits.
Look at the stairs.
I know.
They're so tiny.
Dinner for giants.
Yeah.
This is actual Minto point of view.
Why am I taking strays?
Is it the kitchen?
The meat locker?
The meat locker.
There's always one.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh, there actually is one.
You're right.
Every horror game has to have one.
That is some...
What is wrong with this meat?
Wait, where?
On the table.
It's so colorful.
Christmas.
Yeah, what is this?
Somebody's casserole?
Oh, it's cake?
No.
This is a cake?
It's got like avocado slices on top.
Spare gets weird.
It's a veggie cake.
It's very Midwest potluck inspired.
Uh-oh.
I hear someone coughing in there.
Time gate...
Oh!
Get your gun ready.
Wait!
Don't shoot!
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, he's about to turn.
Yeah.
I can tell.
Are you alright?
Don't touch him!
The fog.
Unless he's got asthma.
We might be judging too early.
Yeah, have you ever thought...
Like, if you had asthma during the zombie apocalypse...
How bad that would suck?
That would be so bad.
Wait, let me go!
It's too dangerous!
The fog.
It's like Silent Hill.
My daughter!
She's all alone!
If we don't do something...
All right.
I get it.
Don't put your hand over his mouth.
He might be infected.
You know...
We don't know how it spreads, right?
We're making the time.
Okay.
I think people that know the game probably know.
That's true.
Where are you?
We're just dropping right in.
Yeah.
We'll figure it out.
Wait, where...
Did that guy leave?
What was that sound?
Yeah.
Oh, he's...
He's brave.
Why'd you run in there?
He's gotta find his daughter.
Oh, God.
That's sad.
Sink jump scare?
Wait, can I...
They're in the vents.
Wait, are they actually?
Thank you?
Oh, gosh.
What are you trying to do?
Aren't they?
A menu popped up for a second.
Oh.
Let me...
I think I could emote...
You could emote?
Yeah!
For now, I don't know where the menu went.
Leon hitting the gritty.
I am.
Oh, my God.
Oh, sorry, mister.
We're coming.
Who turned the lights off?
The hell?
Why are the lights off?
Oh, it's hard to see.
We have a flashlight?
It is.
Oh, maybe we do have one.
It's like beaming from your eyes.
Oh, like a cat.
Exactly.
There's that guy, though.
Oh, here he is.
Oh!
Is your phone out?
I got my phone out on the side.
I don't know how to put it back in my pocket.
No.
I don't know.
Oh, you're like...
Oh, now I see my phone.
Oh.
I think that's the menu.
It shows your inventory and bullets and everything.
Is it just staying forever?
We're about to fight.
Wait, I have no bullets.
Oh, gosh.
We gotta go through here.
Wait, I've got...
I've got bullets, I think.
18 bullets.
You do?
Okay.
We'll leave it to you.
You know, I'm allergic to using ammo in these games.
I'm so...
I got my knife out.
Me too.
President?
Oh, it is the president.
Of the United States.
President Adam Benford.
Oh.
I don't think that's real.
Oh, yeah.
It's AI, everybody.
It's AI.
It's your daddy, please.
The first AI president.
Is she up there?
Who are you looking at, mister?
I'll go check.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I'm emoting.
I can't emote.
Look.
Wait, how do you do that?
Cold B.
It doesn't work.
Oh, wait.
Mike, I'm on...
You're using controller, right?
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
No!
I'm sure you've got emotes too.
Somewhere.
Item slot.
Oh, this queue is, like, where I'm supposed to go.
She's, like, beautiful.
He's floating.
I thought they weren't an item.
That's a person.
I can spray them.
There's health right there, yeah.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
I just stole their first aid spray.
Wait, how do I take that?
Oh, I got it.
What did you do?
No.
You caught me in the eyes.
I think you ran into my knife.
You ran into my knife ten times.
It wasn't my fault.
I swear.
I feel bad.
Can we steal the Declaration of Independence?
In here?
This is suddenly...
Uh-oh.
Has he changed already?
Oh.
Hold on.
Let me see your eyes, mister.
No, she's here.
Somewhere.
Oh!
Keep getting him!
Don't let him...
Where is this going?
But this is the exit, mister.
Why is she in here?
How do you know?
We'll need to get the elevator working again.
He has...
Fifth sense.
I've got the keys.
Once we're in, we can take my car.
Thanks.
Let's find Liz and get the hell out of here.
Liz?
Liz, is that you?
Oh, there's a lot of blood, mister.
Yeah.
It's probably a stage prop.
Probably.
I mean, why else would it be...
Would it be bloody like this?
Right?
It's so perfectly, like...
Symmetric.
It is.
Oh, someone's playing the piano.
Whoa.
Are we afraid of lightning?
Why are we...
Why do we go blind?
It's too bright.
Our eyes are not adjusted yet.
I like how sometimes I run, and sometimes I don't.
I know, right?
I don't understand it quite.
Me either.
Careful.
Uh-oh.
It's a big hand friend.
Are we going in?
I'm going in.
Go.
Oh, you need my help.
One, two.
Look at my shoe.
Three, four.
Open the door.
At the door.
I don't have bullets.
Why is it...
Uh-oh.
I did it auto- I don't...
I don't think she's good.
I don't think so either.
She's about to eat him.
Where are mom and Liam?
They...
They already got out.
They're waiting for us at home.
We can move during the cutscene.
Is this going to be like Red Dead Redemption?
where some silly things happen in the background?
Yes.
Oh, they're just leaving.
Okay.
I was going to say.
Everything's big.
Everything's massive.
This is America, baby.
Everything's huge.
How do we get out of this place?
The underground parking lot.
Where'd you go?
I'm stuck on the body.
I'm coming.
Hopefully it still works.
I'm here.
Walk and run through the halls.
Oop.
What was that?
I don't know.
Oh, just some like 2x4s in here.
This is the skinniest hallway ever.
Why is it so congested?
Let's get this out of our way.
I could...
I would if I could move around this man.
On this?
Uh-oh.
Okay.
I'm coming.
I can yell at you.
Helena.
I'm glad you guys were here.
I don't think she's looking so hot.
Yeah.
Neither is he, though.
You know, maybe they can...
They have asthma together.
Don't you think it's kind of romantic if like 2 people become zombies together and then they're just like wandering?
I think that's his daughter.
Zombies forever.
I'm just kidding.
But, you know, in general.
Oh, in general, yeah.
No,
they're me.
Daughter me.
Familial bomb.
I just think that...
Why are we being so stupid and letting her come with us?
Yeah.
Maybe we have confidence.
We can take him out.
Yeah, that's true.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Liz?
Now we're trapped in the elevator with her.
Yeah.
Oh.
Poor guy.
What a performance.
Uh-oh.
I'm touched.
Oh, no.
In the dark.
Someone's getting chomped on.
Or someone's doing the chomping.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy when they, like, transform.
They become so ugly looking so fast.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, the QT's!
I've always wondered, like, how do you tell a fresh zombie from, like, a dirty human who's just been wandering in the apocalypse, you know?
Yeah, that's so true.
Like, I don't think I would be looking my best in the zombie apocalypse.
In 7, there's, like, so much swamp, too, like...
Yeah, yeah, just going through the dirt.
Yeah.
I'm a dirty human.
Mm-hmm.
Uh, is...
I don't think we're alone in here.
Oh.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Lena, grab your gun.
In the elevator?
I've got my gun.
Oh!
Oh my god!
I'm kicking him!
Kick his ass!
Kick his...
Oh, damn!
Oh, no!
Kick his ass!
Is that guy alive this whole time?
Go, go, go!
Hell no!
Oh, I missed.
Is this...
I love the kicking.
What...
What is the...
This is so, like...
Um...
What's the word?
Wait, where's the QT?
Um...
Left 4 Dead!
Oh, yeah!
Wait...
I'm trying to get...
Yeah!
Oh!
Is there stamina in this?
Yeah!
I don't think so.
I'm tired.
I think there is.
I'm tripping over bodies, though.
There are.
Yeah!
Wait!
Where's the QT?
Where's the...
Symbol that makes me...
Allowed to...
I wanna punch him in the face.
On the ground.
I can't see anything.
It's so dark.
I know it is dark.
Ah!
N'nish him!
That's our cue to get the hell out of here.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Press R?
For what?
Oh, there you are.
Oh!
R doesn't do anything.
Which R?
Hmm...
R bumper...
Does something for me.
Oh, R bumper.
Maybe I should switch to controller.
I mean, this is a console game originally, right?
But you do have to aim.
I know!
That's why I was like, you know what?
I'm gonna take it easy.
Yeah.
Where do we go?
Oh!
We go over here.
Yeah, yeah.
Alaina.
Don't!
Ha, ha, ha, ha!
Ha, ha, ha!
Keep's here yelling.
It's getting louder.
It's getting angrier.
Ha, ha, ha!
We're in a rush!
Mhm-hm.
Oh!
Oh, no!
Don't scream!
No, here!
Oh, I see- Oh.
Uh-oh.
Stop screaming!
Turn around!
I have airpods in!
They can't hear!
No!
Take your airpods out!
Oh my god!
That became really extreme all of a sudden.
Leon, it's too late.
There's nothing we can do.
Aww.
He just wants to be a hero.
Yeah.
You're right.
Let's get the hell out of here.
Where are we going?
I guess...
Back to the chapel.
Yeah, the cathedral.
Is there anything in here?
I'm turning my brightness up.
Me too!
That's a good idea.
Oh my gosh.
Camera settings?
I'm turning it all the way up.
It said like...
Make it so that the 6 is barely visible.
But I had it really visible.
Me too!
I had it really visible.
And it's still too dark.
Graphics settings?
No.
Where did you find it under?
Screen settings?
Oh, here we go.
It's in screen settings.
Let's just turn it up to like...
35, everybody.
Crazy.
Oh, finally I can see.
I know.
Is it going to be really bright when we go outside?
I feel like they just want you to make it dark.
Because the graphics are bad.
And so you can't see how bad the graphics are.
No, it's supposed to be spooky.
He said it was some sort of fog.
The fog.
This thing spread in gas form.
And anyone who breathed it in got infected.
Uh-oh.
This looks like fog.
I know.
Are we in trouble?
Yeah.
But then why is it so quiet?
I've got a bad feeling about this.
Hmm.
Okay, I got my shotgun out.
You have a shotgun?
Yeah, baby.
Did you find one?
I don't know.
Did you start with one?
Maybe I started with it.
I don't remember picking it up, so...
Ooh.
The lecture hall?
This is nice.
Like academia?
It's so...
Like, it already looks so worn down.
How did this happen, like, within the span of...
Yeah, that's true.
Uh-oh.
This guy, this guy did it all.
Sorry.
Didn't really do that.
He's like, my lesson.
Come on.
Oh, there's multiple.
Didn't you hear, Bunny?
If the professor is 15 minutes late, you're legally allowed to...
Whoa!
That guy just disintegrated.
I don't know how many bullets I have, though.
Oh, I...
I'll go...
I'll go kick him.
Yeah!
You got him!
Wait, what is this?
Skill points.
Oh, you can get skill points from the guys that you defeat.
There's skill points?
Oh!
Oh, there's a guy here, too?
Oh, I've got ammo.
Good job.
Nice.
Wait, which way?
This...
I can't tell which...
Where the door is.
This one?
Over here?
Oh, you got him.
I wanted to yell again.
Elena!
Does this work?
No.
Oh, I should.
Are you in a cut scene?
No, are you?
I...
I just saw a big...
The big area out there.
That's all it showed me.
Okay.
I guess it's like, you need to go there.
Or something.
Okay.
Wait, can I yell at you?
Oh
my god!
Crazy!
Can you lock on?
I know, right?
It's so awesome.
Oh my god!
This is awesome.
Yeah!
I don't know.
I like the little cans of like, soda everywhere and stuff.
Yeah.
Wait, there was something?
Oh.
What's going on there?
I'm just role playing like I'm Sanji from One Piece.
Oh!
We don't need...
Where my mind is right now.
We don't need guns.
Wait, do I have...
Oh, I only have my...
I don't have a...
A knife.
Dang.
There's an herb over here.
You don't have a knife?
No!
Just my fists.
There's an herb.
Oh!
Green herb.
Nice.
The Capcom store sells like...
Little like tea bags that's supposed to be the healing herbs.
Does it?
Yeah, it's really cute.
I wanna try it.
Oh wait, there's another door on the other side, I think.
Oh, in here?
Mm-hmm.
I see that guy laying...
Chilling there.
Stab him!
He just wanted...
A Coca-Cola.
You got this!
Yeah!
Get him!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't reach him.
Yeah, get his...
Yeah!
I defeated him.
He didn't move though.
He did.
He did!
Yeah.
He doesn't wanna be disturbed.
He's taking a fine little nap.
I wonder if there are any survivors.
Oh, he saw some.
They...
They didn't last very long.
Uh-oh.
Yeah.
Oh!
Get him!
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh, damn.
He's slicing him.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
I got her.
No, I don't.
Yes, I do.
Oh!
Teamwork!
Yeah!
That was good!
Wait, there's so much ammo.
Oh, wait.
I did get skills.
If you get...
Skills.
I don't have a skill to equip.
Oh, me neither.
Do we have to buy a skill?
I don't know.
Kick and shank.
I was always scared of these games because it always was like, the ammo is so limited.
But if you can just shank everyone, I think it's fine.
Yeah.
Until the zombies will only die after you kick them 400 times.
That's true.
Oh.
Oh, I kicked him twice and that's all I needed.
What's a Resident Evil?
These guys seem weak.
I know in Resident Evil 7 though, the zombies get so strong.
They take like 20 bullets to kill.
Ew!
No!
I know.
That's what I needed.
Wait, there's a room over here.
Oh, I think I'm hurt.
Wait.
How?
Who are you?
QTE!
I tripped over that guy.
I actually tripped over him.
Oh no.
Where'd they come from?
I don't know.
Nasty suckers.
Getting skill points.
Oh, there's grenades here.
Nice.
Is this a different room?
I guess so.
Everything looks the same.
Would these guys be naplings because they're all sleeping?
Yes.
They're like Nemi Nightmare.
They're dreaming for me.
I'm sure they're having horrible nightmares.
That's good though.
That's what you want to eat, right?
Yeah.
It is.
I'm right here!
I tried opening the door.
Christmas.
Get to the security gate.
It'll lead you off the campus.
Okay.
So nice.
Yeah.
A little party.
Oh!
This one's got a weapon.
Yeah!
Nice!
I like when we double up.
It's good.
Of course, big sushi rolls.
Oh my God!
Huge!
This is America.
This is actually what America is like, everybody.
If you've never...
It's very true.
Yeah.
If you've never been.
If you're not American.
One second.
I'm trying.
There's an attempt.
You're succeeding.
Zombies are just having a nice time.
They haven't touched their sushi though.
On a plunge hammer.
Oh my God!
Holy cow!
Can we take it?
I know!
Oh, did you take it?
Oh, I think it's here now.
Oh, you got it!
Or...
I did?
It disappeared once you walked over it.
Disappeared.
Wait, can I disrupt the sushi?
Or a red herb?
Wait, somebody's gonna wanna eat it now.
It's got my butt germs all over it.
No, maybe...
Maybe that makes it better.
There's...
Green herb too.
Green.
Wait, I'm trying to grab the herb.
Oh, I can't?
Maybe I'm full.
Oh my gosh, I saw somebody...
Who got the omurice...
And they asked for a wisp...
To be drawn...
Oh my God!
My butt!
They drew your butt on it instead!
I'm...
I'm surprised they were allowed to do that.
I know!
I was impressed with the...
The...
Cafe Maid's drawing skill too.
It was impressive.
Nice.
Yeah, it was really accurate.
What?
This guy's also got a bottle.
You've been hittin' the bottle too much lately, buddy.
Take it easy.
That's for sure.
I wonder what the weirdest request that these maids get...
I know, right?
On the omurices.
Sorry, not from here.
Try the staff building behind the bleachers.
I'm guessing you'll find keys for the gate there.
I need to mix herbs to make space.
Oh!
Wait, how do I do that?
Okay.
It's definitely in the tutorial and I definitely don't remember.
I'm combining...
I'm mixing...
Herbs.
Oh, like this.
Okay.
Combine.
Oh.
I've combined.
Okay, wait.
Now I can go get more.
They look...
They look weird.
Yeah.
Herb.
Crab.
Okay.
Now if I mix it again...
I can see you running around in the back.
What was it behind the bleachers, she said?
Oh, over here.
I don't know.
Wait, is this the bleachers?
Well, there's always like a little direction, which is kind of nice.
Keep that trigger finger ready.
I know.
This is a very head empty game.
It really is.
Run to the next point on the map.
This guy...
This guy is definitely alive.
He really wants me to spray you.
Am I hurt?
How can I tell?
I don't know.
I'm gonna spray you.
You need some...
It's a body spray.
I'm staying.
I'm stanky.
Oh my gosh.
They're playing football.
Oh, they are.
Go team.
They live in their college dreams.
Oh, did you ever play...
The...
Card shop simulator?
No, I didn't.
Oh.
In that game, you can spray people with deodorant.
No way.
Really?
Yes.
People come into your store stinky.
Oh my gosh.
You can spray them with deodorant.
Wait, will she yell at you?
How do I yell?
Push B.
I don't know what B is for you.
I'm pressing everything.
Lay on.
Oh, I got it.
Hurry up.
Lay on.
Uh oh.
Why did she just press buttons?
This is like me...
Trying to go into my grandparents' house.
The door's locked.
Why?
There's no way out.
They always have the security system armed.
And I never know the password.
And they're always like, Don't worry.
Oh my god.
Just turn the alarm on and then...
And I want my knife.
Get your knife out.
It's knife in time.
Oh my god.
That lady's clipping through the...
You can't take them all.
Now we know all of them.
I think this works.
Oh.
Yeah.
Grab my skill points.
Nice.
Attack.
Oh.
There's so many guys.
That guy was behind me and just didn't do anything.
Come on, guy.
This is a pretty tight security for a college campus.
Oh, there's more.
Yup.
Take them out.
Of course, there's so many.
They're playing football.
I think I'm hurt.
There's a melee point.
Melee skill.
Ah!
Oh no!
What?
You know what?
I'm just gonna start using my gun.
Uh-oh.
Ouch!
Hey!
I've almost got it.
Hang on.
Uh-oh.
Is this, uh, like, your objective?
Is this to survive?
Uh-huh.
I think so.
Oh, I see where my health is now.
I think.
Where is your health?
I think it's the little squares.
It's open!
Get out of there!
Now!
Go!
Uh...
Hello, sir?
You might wanna...
Oh, he's...
He's done for.
There's some bullets here, though.
Oh, there's a PC!
Are we gaming?
Yeah!
Let's play Minesweeper!
Minesweeper!
I've never been good at that game.
Like, I know...
Me neither!
I know the...
The...
The strat, but I don't know.
Oh, there's this, like...
Sometimes it's just luck, right?
I don't...
I think there's actually a strat, though.
I mean, you're not just supposed to click the boxes randomly.
What about the first one, though?
The first one is always luck.
That's true.
You can just get unlucky.
Oh!
What the heck is this?
Whoa, what is that?
Sigil!
That looks important!
Can we take it?
It's, like, glowing and everything.
There's the...
To look at.
Smash it?
Oh!
Perfect symbol!
Oh, I think there is stamina.
I see it, actually.
Come on.
So impatient, Leon Kennedy.
Oh, the key card.
I knew that was gonna happen.
I knew it!
Oh, no, no, no!
Are you alive?
Yeah, I'm okay.
Okay.
I knew that was gonna happen.
I looked around.
I turned around exactly to see it happen.
What about you, lady?
Ah!
I knew it!
So they were...
Resting.
Chilling.
They were just showing off their...
Oh, wait.
My health is bad.
You need some Axe Body Spray?
I'm gonna spray my...
The tutorial did not teach me how to...
Spray myself.
Herb.
Does it show you on your little HUD?
I think if I...
It says red bumper for me.
I think.
I have to equip it, I think.
And then if I equip it...
Wait, huh?
I have to press one.
Oh!
Okay, I'm good to go!
Oh.
It was like a little mint.
Why is it all deodorant and mint?
I'm so...
Yeah, I'm so fresh now.
Whoa!
YB!
Why?
They hate you.
What's their problem?
Because I'm smelling so good.
Yeah.
Oh.
What the hell did I just do?
Who opened this door?
They must have opened it.
That's suspicious.
Just keep beating him up.
We're just bullying him.
Yeah, we really are.
Oh, that's not...
Whoa!
Whoa, you're tough.
Oh, shoot.
Leon's a hero.
Big cool hero.
Big cool hero!
Oh, you dead?
I'm good, I'm good.
But there's skill points here.
I know, I wanna use them.
And I don't know what they're for, but...
They're like, tic-tac.
Hi!
You did it.
You did it, Leon.
We took care of all these guys.
Where'd they come from?
Whoa!
You can see...
Check them.
That's awesome.
Oh!
Hey, lady.
See?
Ouch!
Whoa!
Where'd she go?
Oh, there she is.
I think if I just...
If I just go and unlock it, I think it's fine.
Yeah.
Maybe?
Wait.
You got this!
Yeah!
I'm addicted to the sneak attacks.
Oh.
Maybe you could get that guy.
I think he knows where we are, though.
It's okay.
They're dumb.
I'll... I'll distract them.
Whoa!
This is just that easy.
Just that easy.
If I press... Oh, if I press one...
Oh, okay, okay.
Elena.
Oh, my God.
You were zooming around me.
Very cool.
Leon's got moves.
Wait, can I slide on this?
No?
Yeah, that's what I was thinking.
I wanna go through.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
I feel like it's gonna beep.
Yeah, probably.
It's gonna beep.
I would hope so.
It's gonna sound the guards.
The guards.
Come on, Leon.
He skipped arm day.
Should've known.
Oh, it actually did go on.
I knew it!
Why is it...
I guess the power's still on, huh?
Go, go, go!
No!
Oh, nice.
Oh, there was something there, though.
Uh-oh.
Tickle right up ahead.
You're almost there.
Keep running!
Oh, keep running, she said.
Okay.
Oh.
Ah!
Whoa!
Oh, God.
Run!
Oh, my God.
It's crazy here.
I'm going, I'm going!
Just run!
Run past the police!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
I don't know where...
Are we even flying?
I think you are!
Oh, you're here.
Wait, am I?
No keys?
I'm moving the stick.
Wait, I think you're, like, talking to me, but I'm not in the car.
Get in the car!
Should we hotwire it?
Hotwire it!
Are you in?
Ah!
I'm about to leave!
Yeah, I think I'm in the...
It's clear behind us.
Back up!
It is not clear behind.
No.
Oh, my God.
Rebuckle in?
Oh.
Yeah.
Does that matter right now?
I don't have my license.
It matters.
You want to be buckled up.
Leon, freshly 16.
Without getting killed.
Oh!
That's not good.
She barely made it out.
We made, like, two feet before we crashed.
I know!
No!
Leon, Helena, are you two all right?
I'm hanging in there.
Barely.
Yeah, barely.
Are we going in the sewers?
I found an underground room that may be safer.
In the sewers, huh?
Great.
Time to go... How do we get in?
Oh.
Oh, Jesus.
This game is so...
This is awesome.
I know.
Having so much fun.
Oh.
Whoa!
Oh!
I thought you guys said nothing was going on!
Is it an unrequited love?
Does she like him?
Oh, no.
He doesn't like her.
I feel like it's rude for him to shine his light directly into her eyes like that.
I think there's alligators down here?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, he's...
Oh, God, he's hallucinating.
What is...
Mr. President!
The desire to reveal the truth.
I know where they're coming...
There is actually alligators in the...
In the sewers, though.
In, like, Florida?
Really?
Or everywhere.
What do you mean?
I think so.
I think there are alligators everywhere in Florida.
Like, in your pool?
In your backyard?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'm sure they're in the sewers, too.
I'm right behind you.
And we won't have any chance of fighting this.
In your bathtub?
Crawling up your toilet?
I heard that things can do that.
Yeah, like snakes and stuff?
Yeah.
It's time we take responsibility.
And end this mess.
This is the real romance.
He's such an emo boy with his hair.
Yes.
Let's get moving.
We don't have much time.
Mr. President.
We certainly got our work cut out for us.
Believe me.
I mean, did you see how they were looking at each other?
I know.
Ugh.
This is gross.
Can I walk in it?
Okay, yeah.
You.
Now you really need the ass.
Yeah, I need the spray.
Look at the cute little rat.
Look at him.
It is cute.
Oh, he's really scampering.
He's scampering.
Can I go in here?
He's cute.
He is pretty cute.
They really modeled the rat.
It's not just like a polygon.
There's a dodge?
Oh my god.
Wait.
There's a dodge?
Yeah.
How?
Oh, shoot.
I'm popping my breath mint.
I don't know how to dodge.
That's okay.
Oh.
More rats.
Oh, this doesn't look safe.
Oh, that's gonna...
Yeah.
That doesn't look great.
There can't be zombies down here.
Why would there be people?
Yeah.
But there...
There will be.
But...
They're fast.
Why are they so fast?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Are you good?
Okay.
A caillou came running at us.
When did I switch guns?
There we go.
When can we learn skills?
I know.
Wait.
Can you...
Have you tried yet?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Do we have to go to the skill shop or something?
What are you buying?
It's the only guy I know.
I think he's from four.
What are you selling?
Oh.
I got you.
Thank you.
You saved me.
Uh-oh.
Oh.
There's a lot of guys now.
I'm ready to sneak attack them.
Oh.
That was so close.
Can I sneak attack them?
Oh.
He's about to get behind him.
The train was coming.
Oh my god.
I threw.
I think I died.
I panicked and pushed all the buttons.
Oh no.
Your partner died.
We both died.
Or did you get out of the way?
No.
I died for sure.
Yeah.
I didn't know the train.
Who was running the train?
Yeah.
That was crazy.
Oh.
Nice.
I guess just stay on the sides then.
Yeah.
I'm ready for the QTE.
I didn't even have a QTE that came up.
You didn't?
No.
It's here.
Oh no.
A space art.
I thought it would be the same QTE as last time.
Leon.
That's okay.
Third time's a charm.
Oh no.
Come here.
Come here, buddy.
Oh.
Dang.
I got my ass.
Is the train just gonna come?
No matter what.
Ouch.
Uh-oh.
Train's coming.
Okay.
I pushed it.
You got it.
It probably killed all the guys though, right?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh gosh.
Come on.
I know QTE's too.
No.
He's owning us.
I know this one guy is so...
Oh my gosh.
Why didn't he get got by the train?
He knows QTE's too.
He's comboing us.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
What's going...
Is that a dog?
The dog?
Oh no.
Not the dogs.
Does the dog make that sound?
I think that he was eating a person.
Oh.
I'm gonna blast him.
I took care of him.
Oh, it's so sad when they make the dog move.
Oh, I know.
Why do you have to do that?
I know.
Oh.
Oh no.
I got you.
Oh, you got him.
Dogs are fast.
Oh, why is it so...
Oh gosh.
Oh, ow.
What's happening to me?
What?
Oh gosh.
More dogs.
I'm spraying.
I didn't need to do that.
Are you okay?
I'm trying to kick the dog in.
They're too low.
Yeah.
For being enraged with my knife.
Maybe...
Maybe I should use my gun.
I don't even know how the...
My heals came out.
I don't know how that happened.
I don't...
I didn't press any...
Maybe...
What did I press?
Oh, caps lock does that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Interesting.
The tutorial didn't teach anything.
It really didn't.
Oh, there's two people wrestling over here.
Okay.
I can save them!
Oops.
The train!
Oh no!
I don't know where...
It's okay.
It was right here.
Yeah, it was right here.
I got this guy now.
I'll save him.
Why do I shoot him?
Why do I shoot the wrong guy every time?
Oops.
I can't engage with the zombie.
Cause I know it's too...
Okay, the train!
The train!
Oh, that was close.
As soon as I start fighting a zombie, that's when the train comes.
Okay, we keep going.
Oh!
Even when they die here, they like drop their loot.
That's so nice.
I know.
Just let the train do it.
Yeah.
Oh, it looks electrified.
Oh my god!
Crazy!
Oh, run he is.
I'll shoot him.
Or he could die on his own, I feel.
Oh.
He should be.
Ah!
Oh, he's still standing there.
He's still st...
Ah!
Oh, shoot!
He's still...
Got a pipe!
I got his butt.
Can we turn it off?
Um...
Oh, I just know the train is coming any second now.
If you come here...
Oh, do we just go this way?
Yeah, yeah, we go this way.
They won't come through, right?
They don't know how to climb.
You need a buddy to go through.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Watch out!
It's very dark in here.
I know, I was gonna say.
Even with the gamma all the way up.
How would we have been able to see otherwise?
I know!
Oh, they're coming down!
Look at these tiny little flashlights.
They're coming down to me!
Should we run?
Oh, yeah.
Just run.
No.
More tracks.
Oh!
Oh, look a serpent thing!
Oh my gosh, they're here.
Ow!
Oh,
behind you!
Oh!
Nice.
Nice!
Yeah!
I'm ready to go shopping.
We're getting... I know!
We're getting so many skill points!
How do I...
Wait, what do I do with this?
Do I shoot this?
Maybe.
I'll shoot it.
Aha!
Nice.
So they can unlock a nice little JPEG to look at.
I love behind the scenes.
I guess we just keep going.
What's that sound?
Is that train sound?
My worst enemy in this game!
Train?
Oh, wait.
Or...
Something.
I don't know.
Something's going on.
Ah!
Uh-oh.
We can take them!
Can we?
Oh my gosh.
Or we could run.
Whoa.
Train!
Are you okay?
I'm okay.
Oh.
Nice.
Get his butt!
It might come...
Am I coming the other way?
Yeah, I was outside.
Ow!
At least they don't make you do a QT.
Oh!
I just hit the QT and I failed it.
This guy's got an axe in him.
Yeah.
Can I have that?
Why is this guy so strong?
Oh my gosh.
I'm just gonna blast him.
He axed me to kill him.
He did, I saw it.
Oh, there's a skill point over here.
Yeah.
Grab all the good...
Oh, if...
Wait, why are there guys dead over here?
Oh, the train.
I already forgot.
Excellent.
My worst enemy and my best friend both.
Train.
Train, my beloved.
It could be enemies to lovers, Ark, you know?
It could be.
There it is.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Are we gonna ride it?
It just lost power though.
Oh.
No!
It really isn't our lucky...
It means it won't be running us over.
Oh my gosh, this guy started crawling at you.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, so what...
We're getting in?
What did he say?
I think we have to climb.
Oh.
Oh, I'm gonna lift you up.
Helena.
Okay.
Wait, are we separating?
No!
Yeah, you gotta open the door for me.
Helena.
I'm glad you're here.
Hello?
Why do you say it twice?
This way.
This guy definitely moved earlier.
There it is.
Why does he only get me?
What?
Jerk.
Yeah.
Look at her heels.
I know.
She's styling.
Is she even a zombie?
I was gonna say, she looks really healthy.
What's wrong with you?
She looks fine.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
We can save him.
Helena.
We're in no rush.
Come on.
Oh.
Why is my gun now?
You know why.
Oh.
Wait, did you just get hurt by something?
Come on.
No.
I just heard a scary sound.
Helena.
Is this like that one anomaly game?
We're supposed to be spotted the difference?
Or we just saw an endless loop?
In this train?
Hey.
He doesn't even care for her name anymore.
Oh.
Good work.
Ah.
Oh, there's people behind us?
Oh.
We're getting off the train.
I think we're getting off the train now.
Oh my god.
Damn.
He hit me hard.
I wish I could do a jump attack.
I know.
I'm helping.
I think you're doing like 90% of everything right now.
No.
I'm just swinging my knife around.
That's the game.
Wait, I think this is the lady.
I screamed.
You okay?
Oh.
Pretty lady?
Pretty lady.
Just kidding.
If you like survived up until now, why would you come out of your hiding spot?
I feel.
Yeah.
Like, I feel like you could make it.
Okay, I'm gonna press this button and it might activate an alarm.
Did you see these bombs?
Oh!
Was there a bomb?
Over here.
Oh.
I had to say Peter!
Please!
Leon.
It's never gonna get you.
That's right.
No!
Don't open that!
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's her fault.
Peter!
Well...
Why would you think this is a smart thing to do?
Oh, there are bombs here.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I placed a bomb.
What?
Blow it!
Let them get closer.
Wait, someone's spitting.
Yeah.
They're missing.
I think you can blow it up now, right?
Ooh!
Oh.
Wait, they all got him.
Oh, we can go finish him off.
Yeah.
They're probably...
They're weak now.
Oh, dang.
Get some air time.
Uh-oh.
We need backup.
No.
We got this.
Who's coming?
Ouch.
Maybe, maybe Ada.
Whoever that is.
Yeah.
Ow!
Ooh, they're sp...
Ew, they're spittin', they're spittin'.
Are they toxic?
Ew.
Yeah, toxic.
I'm...
I have one mint left.
That's ironic.
Oh!
Where'd that person come from?
Ah!
Oh, they're coming for the body!
Oh!
Did I die?
Don't do that.
Get outside.
You died?
No.
I got bit...
She tore a chunk out of my neck, but I'm fine.
Oh, okay.
You're not infected or anything.
It's...
It's fine, probably.
Yeah.
Only if you breathe the fog, right?
Yeah!
Wait, so this goes...
Wait, no.
Um...
Uh...
How do I...
Okay.
I'm learning.
I think I'm stuck.
What?
Oh!
You made it.
You can reach the street level from there.
What are conditions like up there?
This thing is really fun.
Hell on Earth isn't much of a stretch.
We didn't pay.
It makes a nice sound.
It does.
Usually they don't let you go back, you know?
I know!
It's a one-way street.
Nice.
Say it.
This is my favorite part of this game.
Just needy Leon.
Yes!
I'm glad you're here.
How do you say that?
You two will have to cross that part of town to get to the cathedral.
I don't know.
I hold me.
Keep your lines open in case you run into trouble.
Nice.
Thanks for that.
Oh, I got it too.
Oh, I can praise.
Good work.
Oh, I just took...
Dang it.
Nice.
Appreciate it.
Fall back.
Wait.
The music is so...
This way.
Why can't I say it anymore?
Oh.
Move it.
Good work.
It doesn't work.
I appreciate it.
Wait, maybe if I hold V and then...
Oh, here we go.
Good job.
Oh.
Yeah.
Thanks for that.
Move it.
It feels a little passive-aggressive.
They're just going back and forth.
Thanks.
Thanks for that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Oh.
We can't save him.
Save yourself.
Slice him.
Wait.
I thought it was a headshot.
Come on.
This game.
Leo, look out.
Ah!
Oh.
GTA!
That's the cars!
Wait, is that a live person?
Wait, are these people?
These are people!
These are people like people.
These are real people!
Oh.
This guy's dead.
Are you okay?
No.
Oh!
Lay off the horn!
Noisy!
Wait, there's something here.
What did I miss?
Skill point?
Oh.
Ew!
The water is gross.
Oh, that's Raccoon City, baby.
I guess we just keep running.
Oh my god!
Are you okay?
Leo.
Hold on.
I'll get you out.
Oh, we'll get you out.
Oh my god!
Wow!
Oh.
Everything's gone to hell.
Oh my god.
This is crazy.
Just run for it!
Redbird!
We don't have time to deal with it.
Go, go, go!
Am I going the right way?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
Up the ladder.
Oh my god!
They're having a little party, dance party down there.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Okay, I'm gonna jump.
I don't know how to climb, right?
Oh!
Every time I get grabbed, I just reflexively start spinning my control stick.
Oh, is that what you're supposed to...
Is that what the QT is?
Sometimes for me.
Gotta be ready.
Yeah.
Look at Caillou.
Oh.
Over here.
There's no time.
There's a bit crying.
I'm in a bad case of deja vu.
I'm just running.
Yeah, me too.
I don't want to travel.
Wait.
Just keep going.
Okay.
Hey, get out of our way, buddy.
I want a hug!
Oh, Nippy Nightmare, I'm your biggest fan!
Where do we...
Oh.
Not enough.
They're pretty strong!
They're very strong!
What the hell?
Oh, ouch!
Who's shooting me?
Oh.
Oh my god!
Oh, I think I'm...
What?
Oh, I'm good.
Okay.
Can I help you?
Wait, where are we going?
Oh, this way.
Up here.
I'm blind.
Me too.
Oh, gosh.
This person made it even less far than we did.
Oh, my god!
Crazy.
Every time I get to one of these, I just spam the button.
Is that true?
The fog.
Oh, yeah.
It's really...
It is foggy in here, right?
I feel like we're doomed.
Yeah.
Could just be smoke.
From...
Is it dinner time?
I think we should have a drink!
Hell yeah!
Yeah.
Oh.
She said to stay inside and we immediately go back outside.
That's fine.
Alright.
It's a one-person door.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh, no!
I think we go in here.
Oh!
There's this little skill point over there.
I don't even know where we are or going.
Why are they all dead?
Oh, somebody's house?
Wait, did they...
What happened to you guys?
They've...
Maybe decided they didn't want to live through the zombie apocalypse.
Look at this guy's mouth.
It's like a Kingdom Hearts cutscene.
Caution.
They do not yet know who is responsible.
KMGTuber.
Yeah!
Oh.
I hear fire.
This is crazy.
I think they're gonna come at us.
Oh, this guy's gonna come at us.
Nope.
Okay.
It's locked.
I'm standing on him.
Locked.
Locked?
Oh!
Find a key.
Okay.
Oh.
Good thing they tell you where the key is.
I don't.
There's no mystery here.
It's very head empty.
You can just run around.
I don't.
Run to the next...
Marked point on your map.
Oh.
How romantic.
Map.
Hello?
He looks fresh.
He does.
Oh.
Okay.
He doesn't look so fresh anymore.
It happens so fast when they change.
It's like...
It does.
Crazy.
This guy's gonna get up.
Oh.
There it is.
Oh!
Oh, thank you.
The physics...
Physics are crazy.
I'm learning...
Oh, a shotgun!
I'm learning this game now.
Oh!
Better shotgun.
Bigger shotgun?
Sorry mister.
Oh.
We are cussing.
This looks like a boss.
A boss?
Yeah.
Ooh.
Ooh!
Yeah!
That's why they gave us a better gun.
Oh yeah.
I might even use it.
I'll get the guys up here.
You got...
Ooh!
Oh, you got him?
Is he not a boss?
He just ran away instantly.
What am I jumping over?
Oh.
Ooh!
There it is.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh shoot!
I got you!
Ah!
Oh shoot!
What's happening?
I don't even know!
Oh my god!
Oh no!
Oh thank you!
Where is he?
Let me...
There's no way he opened and closed this door.
There's no way.
He might have.
He's got manners.
Oh!
Is that him?
Yeah, that's him!
Oh my god!
He looks like the thing from, uh...
What's it called?
The...
The monster in Dead by Daylight.
What?
Which one?
Damn it!
Which Dead by Daylight?
There's like a guy.
He's...
I think he's called the Unknown.
Oh.
Oh he dropped...
You like Dead by Daylight?
I've never...
I've played a little bit, but I've never like gotten super into it.
Yeah, me too.
I think we go upstairs.
Do we?
He gave...
That seemed like a giant totem.
Of a skill point.
Leon.
Hurry it up.
We really still not get any skills.
I know, right?
Where do we get to pay the money?
Up and over.
Oh!
Whoa!
That was impressive.
You ready?
Oh, are you coming over?
Or...
Okay.
I don't know.
I got this all on my own.
I don't know, I jumped.
I'm going.
Don't...
You handle it.
I'm pushing something.
Okay.
Don't worry about it.
I'll fight.
Okay, keep fighting.
I'm pushing.
Oh, I can just hold it.
Ow, ow, ow.
Oh, I got another bite.
What the hell just happened?
Uh-oh.
Um...
Uh, I think I unlocked this for you.
Uh-oh.
I think I might be dying.
I might have died.
I need you.
I'm nothing without you.
I got you.
This...
Oh, from here again?
Oh no, back here.
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
This guy was nothing.
We need to watch this again.
He was easy peasy.
He actually was.
What is that?
I like this new gun.
It's nice.
Oh yeah?
I wouldn't know.
Wait, this doesn't only use the dice.
Oh.
Wait, what just happened to me?
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh.
Why were they in cages?
Good question.
They're locked away.
It's jail.
Actually, maybe it's like one of the...
Pinata!
Oh!
I got you!
Oh my god, he's here!
Don't leave!
Where?
Oh, dang it.
I had to reload.
Uh-oh, I don't have very many bullets left.
Where'd he go?
Oh, there he is.
He's running.
Oh, that's not him.
I'm chasing him down.
Get his ass!
He's scared!
Kill him.
Take his super skills.
Yeah.
Okay.
That's interesting.
I thought he would like, run to the area.
I thought you too.
You ran, like, all the way back.
I'm scared.
Do you have any ammo?
No, mister?
Okay.
Can I give you my ammo?
Wait, do you have ammo?
Yes.
A little bit.
For this gun.
I'll try and use it sparingly.
Okay, now we go up here.
Or, we go here, yeah.
And we're like, it's locked.
Then we go up here.
And then I won't die this time.
Just...
Just hold it out.
You can give ammo?
Can you?
I'll be faster this time.
Okay.
Oops.
I'm pushing!
I'm going as fast as I can!
Alright, I think I open this for you.
Down here.
Where?
Maybe this door here, yeah.
Uh-oh.
I'm just hiding.
It's open!
I'm coming!
Sometimes being a coward works.
Oh, gosh.
Watch out!
He's behind you.
I was...
I was reading the ketchup and mustard bottles.
Can we shut the door?
Why do we leave it open?
We should be able to.
Oh, I did it again.
Oh, there's a thingy here.
Serpent emblem.
Oh!
Um...
Wait, I can just knock it with my hand.
Yes.
Maybe.
Punch it.
I can't...
I'm too weak.
Uh-oh.
I got it.
Oh, come on, guys!
Leave us alone!
He kind of does...
This area reminds me of Silent Hill.
Wait, did he drop anything?
Nope.
Over here.
I'm coming!
Oh, my God.
Good question.
I don't want to die!
Oh, no.
Oh, there's a lot.
Come on.
We have to help him.
We do?
Alright.
Can these guys live for once?
Oh, come on.
I pressed R.
Oh, my aim.
Wait, Peter.
Peter again?
There's Peter.
Oh, my God.
Eliminate all enemies.
Who made you the leader?
Okay.
Peter is a sought-after man, isn't he?
Wait, was he...
Oh, was he the guy that...
I think I died.
You died.
What was that?
There was no quicks...
Or no...
I don't know.
Where?
There was nothing to help with that.
Oh, my goodness.
Where's the cutie?
Don't be there.
Don't be anywhere else.
I know, right?
Oh, oh.
Oh, damn.
Alright.
Oh, they're calling them cannibal freaks.
Is this like the Walking Dead universe where the concept of zombies doesn't exist?
Maybe.
Oh!
Hello.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh!
Ouch!
I'm loading on him.
We get out of the way.
Ouch!
Yeah, let's get out of the way, maybe.
Peter, wait!
Peter!
I'm just waiting for the ambulance to show up.
I'm just gonna bury him.
Oh!
Why is it going a different way?
Okay, never mind.
What the hell?
Ow!
Oh, my gosh.
Can you imagine if friendly fire was actually on this?
Oh!
Ow!
I think I died!
Wait!
No, I'm not dead.
I'm alive!
Who got me?
I don't know.
Who's this guy?
There we go.
Can I take your gun?
Shoot the gas!
We can blow these things to Kingdom Cup!
I think we should get further away if we do that.
Oh!
I hate this guy.
I know, he's annoying.
Some zombies with guns.
Move out of the way, Mr. Police!
Marsh, there are zombies with guns.
Yeah.
Oh, we got him.
Nice.
I'm taking your skill points.
Ow!
Oh, should we blow it up?
Yeah, they're like, hello, are you gonna blow it up?
Yeah.
He's getting knocked out.
Beautiful fire.
Fireworks.
Gunshot?
Oh, I hope they have melee weapons at the gun shop.
Wait, I'm gonna grab a...
I don't see any other options.
Ammo and stuff for us.
Is there loot?
Oh yeah, there is loot!
I see it.
Good thinking.
The loot, grab the loot!
Actually, there's not that much.
Yeah.
They better have something good at the shop.
Yeah,
I want a better melee weapon.
I want a knife.
At the gun shop.
A machete!
I want a katana!
Hello!
Okay.
Why don't we shut doors behind us?
I know!
I got a grenade.
But where's the rest?
Oh, here's some.
You just took it?
You just stole it?
Yeah.
Oh, me too.
Wait, but why can't we grab great guns?
And that's no way?
Oh, he's got ammo too.
Where?
Why can't we grab the guns?
This seems a little backwards.
We're robbing him.
Oh.
Lady, are you gonna do anything?
Yeah, get his butt.
Oh.
Trying not to shoot you, but I guess it doesn't matter because I turned it off.
Did you just dodge?
Somehow.
I
just skewed, kind of like, in my cut scene.
Yes.
You're doing the... the goal shooting.
You're kicking the camera.
Ah, yeah!
I am.
Oh.
Oh, I thought I was loaded.
Oopsie.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I...
Romance!
Yeah.
Oh, come on.
That... that hit.
That hit.
Crazy!
Spare the heroic!
She's just slowing us down anyway.
Oh.
What's the matter with you?
She's your girlfriend.
Is my gun not good anymore?
Oh!
Are you okay?
I don't know.
I'm in trouble.
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
You finished me off!
I... I guess so.
Nice!
Good job!
Oh, dang it.
I'm just letting the NPC do the work.
Yeah.
And you.
And you!
And me!
Oh!
The jankiness is so good.
It is.
Wait, there's an axe body spray?
Where?
Right here?
Oh yeah, on the counter.
I'll take it.
What?
They're not gonna stop coming!
My gun's jammed!
What?
You're in a gun store!
Oh!
She's gonna get shot!
You idiots can fight it out if you want!
I'm getting the hell outta here!
Okay.
I wonder if the guy upstairs just got shot then.
Oh, I see it.
Yeah.
Uh, alright.
Oh!
Ow!
Are you okay?
Are they in here?
Is it a gun zombie?
Oh, yeah.
How do they know how to do that?
Get the hell away from me!
They're triggered at...
They're American.
That's why.
In their...
In their instincts.
Yeah.
In their blood.
What are you doing, buddy?
There's no time for theatrics!
Yeah, you deserve that.
Ew!
I don't know why he got this thing after.
Ooh!
New enemy type?
Oh, was that Peter?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
I got flashbanged.
Am I gonna punch you?
Punch me?
Oh gosh.
Ah!
Oh!
Oh my god.
I keep getting flashbanged.
Ow!
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
What the heck was that?
That was crazy.
It got like insane all of a sudden.
Insane.
Are we all the way back at the beginning?
Are we back at the start?
Oh wait, no.
We're not.
Oh, okay.
Good, good, good.
Thank you.
We get to launch this again.
We're at the part where it just gets freaky enough.
Yeah.
Do we get hurt by our own bombs, I wonder?
I don't know.
I feel like we should, but maybe not.
I can't tell what kind of game this is.
If it's going for that kind of realism or not.
I know.
Did that take it out?
No.
Oh.
Ow!
Oh, good job, good job.
He just fell.
Is he still...
Oh, he's still up.
Can't tell.
Oh my gosh!
It's like all...
All armor?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Oh my god, they're coming in here too!
I got you!
Mister!
I'm going back to the game.
Not a shoddy...
Kinda gal.
I just...
I just love...
Melee.
Even when it's banned.
That's fair.
How do you be quiet?
Okay.
You have this the whole time!
Mister!
Oh.
Don't forget the healing spray.
If you didn't grab it again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's nothing really.
We can't grab any new guns.
We can probably buy some up here.
Maybe, yeah.
Let me use my skill points.
Oh man!
We are rich in skill points.
We are!
Nice work down there.
Good news is...
I got some folks coming for me in a bus.
Any minute now.
If we can make it on board, it's a straight shot to Tall Oaks Cathedral.
Is he gonna take us too?
I don't know.
Does she look okay to you?
We ain't waiting for any stragglers.
Her eyes are glowing a little bit.
Yeah!
Is that normal?
Japanese dude!
Gramps.
There's a guy?
There's a big guy in here.
Zombies are going after each other now too.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ah!
Ha ya!
Oh my god!
Fuel!
Fuel point!
Yeah!
Nice!
Stop making so much noise over here!
More!
When does it end?
Aren't we supposed to close the shutters?
I don't know.
It didn't say anything.
I think we just...
Survive.
Oh!
There you go!
Wait!
There's still a guy in here!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Come on people!
Ha ha ha ha!
There we go.
Oh my gosh!
Anything else?
Oh!
Don't forget to combine your herbs.
Yeah, yeah.
There's actually quite a bit in here.
We're just...
Oh!
What is this?
Ha ha!
Oh!
They better let us shop!
I know!
They can't just tease us with the idea of a shop!
Ew!
Oh!
There's someone right outside the window!
Uh oh!
Wait!
Why did you blow open the window?
Old man is just standing there.
He doesn't care at all.
Is this an earthquake?
Oh!
Big one!
A hunker!
Oh no!
Oh my gosh!
Take
a medicine!
Oh my gosh!
He's too flexed me!
Pulled out of
the...
A chute on this man!
He's so choppy!
He's gonna be in the corner!
He's gonna bring this whole place down on us!
His...
Tits are huge!
He's wearing a diaper, I think!
It's okay.
I think it's...
Right at this point.
I hope...
It better be.
Yeah.
Now I'm...
Now I'm ready.
Now I'm prepared.
I don't know if I'm prepared for that thing!
That guy was huge!
Oh!
I know!
It's such a small room!
It is!
Woo!
Dammit!
Any more waste?
The floor's gonna collapse!
I need to dodge both.
Oh yeah, I forgot that's a thing.
Come on, you become a jen!
Yeah!
Ha ha ha!
Somebody's standing in the other room!
Ow!
He's gonna bring this whole place down on us!
Oh wait!
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Just unload on him!
Reload please!
Oh!
Is he down there?
I think he's down!
Come on!
Move it!
Oh, don't forget the skill points!
Oh, there's a zombie right here?
Oh!
Oh, nice one!
My skill points!
Wait, I didn't get to get the herb!
I want my money!
Can I get the herb still?
I think I gotta...I gotta combine mine.
Oh, I can't!
Wait...
I'm too...I have too much...not enough space.
Wait, if I put this in my slot...
Hold on, I'm still trying to figure out how to do this.
My...my inventory is full of ammo.
Yeah, me too!
Okay, now I can combine.
Oh my god!
Get outta here!
There's still guys coming!
There's always guys!
Is there stuff in here?
Oh, there's grenades in here!
Oh!
Oops!
Never prepared!
The kicks are just so satisfying!
I know!
Okay, so then I click E and I click...
Combine...
Okay!
Nice!
Alright!
Now I'm ready!
Okay!
Are you gonna shut it, old man?
Or...
Is this it?
No, we'll get around to it.
Oh yeah, there's some grenades in there.
Yeah, I didn't even check in here.
Okay, nice.
I need to use...
How do I use my grenades?
I don't know how to swap.
Um...
Hmm...
Should be same as how you swap your weapon.
It's like...
A different menu though, I think.
It means...
One is up, down, and one's left, right.
Oop!
Now it feels like the...
Left 4 Dead party, for real.
We got old man.
Uh huh.
Oh my god!
Help him!
Anybody gonna help him?
They're helping him.
They all ran to him.
Oh no!
Big baby!
He's so heroic!
I know.
He just met us too.
Fast.
Yeah.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Where did you come from?
That guy's on fire!
He's on fire!
Oh my gosh.
I'm reloading right in front of him.
Ow!
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Is that our...
Is that our ride?
Is that our Uber driver?
That's our...
Oh Uber driver, is
he...
Oh my gosh!
Please stop knocking me down.
You're obsessed with me, or something mister.
There we go.
Yeah.
Take my skill...
Oh no!
I run, and I run.
And I grab, and I run.
I'm going down.
Me too.
I'm right behind ya.
I don't like that the sewer is open here.
It makes me think we're gonna have to go back in.
Something's gonna happen to the bus.
It'll explode spontaneously.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, the baby!
There's someone walking our way.
Oh, we gotta shoot the baby.
Big baby.
Come on.
Why is everybody else going to the cathedral too?
I know.
I would get out of town.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm out?
Oh, shoot.
You know what?
Maybe this gun is the best for this.
Oh my god.
What happened?
There's really crazy stuff going on.
You did it.
Did the old man die?
I think so.
I don't know.
That can't be good for the undercarriage of the bus.
Who will think of the condition of the bus?
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Oh, I earned a dog tag.
I've got six deaths.
You only have two.
Oh, I forgot I'm Helena.
I was like, wow.
Rank A.
Look at our enemies.
They're so close.
It's true.
I'm at... My big head's blocking it.
No, it's okay.
I'm at 191.
And... 192.
192 for Nimi.
What?
How many chapters are there?
I don't know.
I didn't realize that... That was only one chapter.
I know.
It was so long.
I thought it was just gonna keep going forever.
Are we just slow?
You know?
I don't know.
Four chapters?
Oh, people are saying five or six.
Okay.
That's not fun.
Chapter one is long.
Next chapter is also crazy long.
Five in total.
What do you want to do?
I could do another one.
How long is crazy long?
Like this long?
Yeah.
Is it like two hours long?
Or like five hours?
Maybe we need to go faster.
They're all long?
They're all long.
Three to four hours?
Three?
I can't tell when... Did you pause in the middle of it?
I know, right?
I can't tell when they're pulling our leg or not.
Game is just long.
I did look it up after.
And it said like the campaign was like 20 hours.
20 to 30 hours.
Really?
I thought it was only like 12.
I thought it would be shorter because it's co-op, right?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well, we can pause in the middle of it.
Oh, we can?
I think.
Yeah.
Oh, it says... Yeah.
They'll say it'll check point and you can continue.
Okay.
And we keep going.
Yeah.
Let's keep going.
And then when we feel like we're done, we can just...
Yeah.
We'll like check... I guess that's for... It's maybe 30 hours for all the campaigns.
The on campaign is 10 hours.
Ah... Ah... Really?
Okay.
Wait, can we buy skills?
Oh, yeah.
I clicked... Continue and it's not doing anything.
Oh, I probably have to continue also.
Oh.
Oh, what can we buy?
Oh!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh, this is... You can lock on!
Wait...
Melee!
You need that one.
I have to get melee.
Yeah, you have to get that one.
Oh, that's like all of my points.
I know.
How many points do you have?
Uh, 13,000.
Rocksteady.
That's all my points.
Reduces recoil.
I might do that one.
Critical hit.
I wish I had enough for piercing.
I know, I almost have enough to get defense too.
Oh!
Maybe I'll get like some of...
Maybe defense.
Scroll down, there's more.
Oh, there is more!
Oh!
Oh, I was like...
I didn't see the scroll right here.
I mean...
Wait, there's a lot more.
Yeah.
Sniper rifle?
Oh!
Lone Wolf.
Keep...
Keeps your partner from helping you when you're in trouble.
That's so messed up!
What?
Don't...
Don't get that one.
Oh yeah, I want the game to be more difficult.
Yeah!
Lows you to easily break free.
Oh gosh.
Wait, now there's so much more!
I know.
A lot of them are expensive.
Yeah, they are.
Transcens your partner's attacks.
Oh, single player only.
Ah.
Single player only?
Whatever.
Increases strength of attacks on a zombie.
Wait.
On a zombie.
Not me.
Where do you see snipe block ones too?
Yeah, me too.
I think eagle eye.
Is this a sniper skill?
I mean, zombie hunter seems good, right?
We're fighting zombies, right?
I'll get the eagle eye.
We need stamina.
Is there a stamina one?
Is there?
I don't know.
Oh yeah, stamina would be great, right?
Yeah, it would be.
Really increased...
Oh, I can't...
I can't afford that.
Com...
Oh, combat gauge.
I don't have that!
That's cost 70,000!
Alright, to equip.
Thank you, guys.
Yeah, don't forget to equip it once you buy it.
Yeah.
Yes.
Maybe critical hit?
Oh.
I guess since you can only get three...
Yeah.
...skills.
Maybe you should choose wisely.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll just save my money.
True.
I'll get these too.
I don't know.
Because some of them you can like level up too.
I think those ones are good to invest in also.
Because you can just keep leveling it up, but it stays in one slot.
Maybe I will get defense.
You know what?
Let's get defense.
Defense seems good.
Yeah.
I can always switch out something else.
Cool.
I'm ready.
I don't know.
Now I want more...
More money.
I know.
Can we get better weapons?
Ever?
Yeah, I want to buy weapons now too.
I know.
This better be a good upgrade.
This better be a big upgrade.
Oh, Hitman's driving the car.
Used!
Not Neo Umbrella.
How was that Umbrella cord?
Oh, I thought we were in Raccoon City.
Are you not so too?
I don't know what's in that cathedral.
I got suits breathing.
We're not?
Suits.
Oops.
Specifically, Derek C.
Simmons.
National Security Advisor.
Not Derek C.
Oh, he looks like...
He looks like, um...
The Green Devil.
Don't call me then.
Who is the Green Devil?
I meant the Green Devil!
Legally Distinct Green Goblin.
I thought it didn't sound right.
But I couldn't remember it.
Oh dear.
How did this happen?
Oh my god, there's so many all of a sudden.
Ah!
Oh!
Back up!
Oh, I can shoot.
Oh!
Wait, why can't I shoot anymore?
We're going nowhere.
You want to aim again, I think.
Oh, okay.
Face yourself!
Whoa!
You just locked heads.
Why is it acting so strange?
The camera.
I know.
Classic cameras.
No, not another car!
Every time.
These games are, like, insane.
Where if something can go wrong, everything will go wrong.
Right?
I don't know.
I'm thinking about, like, the appeal of this game.
Because it is, it's very much like, action movie.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Are there people who are like, I just want to play a game that's like, my favorite action movie.
And you're, like, the hero.
The protag.
Yeah.
Aw, no, I just...
What's his name?
47?
Yeah.
47.
Oh, you were at the cathedral, though.
Yeah.
What's so special about the cathedral, anyway?
She's obsessed.
She is.
Well, she's keeping it secret, right?
She's like, I know the answer.
Yeah.
Ooh, this area's spooky.
Yeah, this is supposed to be a horror game franchise.
It's supposed to be.
Yeah.
Wait, what's around here?
This area's spooky.
I like it.
Oh, that's a big bird.
Oh, watch out!
Oh, oh, oh!
Why did he jump over you to get to me?
He did.
He jumped right over me to get to you.
Dang, you're making me take my medicine because of him.
Jeez.
These are, like, advanced zombies.
I'm expecting to be much stronger.
I know.
I hate it.
What the fuck?
Are you okay?
He...
Oh my god!
He just, like...
I'm just in there now.
Oh my god!
Oh, you got him.
Was there anything in there?
No.
Just goop?
Just goop.
That was so funny.
You just slipped right on in.
I thought I was supposed to be there.
With how it set me down.
I can't tell exactly if I'm going the right way, but I guess it's all lit up.
It's narrowed this way, so it's gotta be nice.
Nice.
Oh!
Why do we always get flashbanged by the...
I know.
It's a good thing that the, you know, the bites don't infect you.
I...
Yeah.
The...
They don't even follow their own rules.
Sucks that 70% of people got infected, but we're just built different.
But we're just built different.
Wait.
I see it.
Cathedral?
What's in here, though?
Is this something?
Is this anything?
Oh.
There's a guy behind you.
Oh, you...
Oh, wait.
He just dropped to the ground and started crawling for no reason.
It's...
It's a big bed in here.
Ooh!
Ow!
Oh, space.
Oh, no.
It's a gate.
Nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Advanced zombies.
You guys are just corpses.
How are you still...
Oh.
That was freaky.
Wait.
How did I die?
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know.
Did he explode or something?
Ow!
Oh.
How did I die?
I was just taking medicine and I died.
My bad.
He hates you.
Sorry.
You're in a vendetta.
I know.
But did I get struck by...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
No way.
We're all the way back here.
No, don't worry.
Just fast.
We can just run.
Yeah.
We can just run through it.
To reach the cathedral.
Do you actually get struck by lightning?
I guess it is raining.
I don't think that's real.
The lightning is a zombie too.
Oh, now there's no...
There is lightning, I guess.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
There is lightning.
There is.
I'm running.
Run.
Okay.
Oh, they're all coming for you.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait.
They're really coming for you.
Oh!
I just slipped into the wall.
Oh.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, God.
It's terrible.
I'm coming.
I'm running.
Just go.
Oh.
Oh, the humanity.
We need some body spray stacked.
I think I have some still.
Unless I accidentally used it.
I don't remember.
Wait.
Was there stuff in here?
There was.
Just a grenade though.
No, no, no.
I wish we could take these...
Those shovels or something.
Yeah, right?
Oh.
Wait.
Please.
There it is.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Oh, my God.
He just ran.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm just gonna shoot.
Oh, my God.
At least there's no lightning inside.
True.
I don't know how you're supposed to dodge the bolt of lightning from the sky.
Oh, I'm sorry though.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
It's locked.
Just go over.
Just climb it.
We'll figure something out.
Maybe there's a key.
That wouldn't be that hard to climb.
A key somewhere.
Oh.
Did I get him?
Oh, I did.
Oh, in here?
Key.
Oh, I didn't even notice this door before.
I didn't either.
Come on.
I'm trying.
It's Hawaiian.
Oh!
Flog in the bathroom.
Oh.
I had one shot.
He's leaving.
I saw a skill over there.
Dang.
Well, we gotta go there.
Toilet.
Holy.
Anybody would fall into that.
Right?
That happened to me once.
I was at my grandpa's.
No.
And he...
I was in the middle of the night.
So I didn't notice that he didn't put the toilet seat down.
No.
Before I went to sleep.
And I was too tired to...
No.
Oops.
I did not know.
I just fell right in.
Oh, no.
Oh.
That's a true story, everybody.
Were you a kid?
Yeah, I was a kid.
Oh.
Nice.
Wait, did you get a key in here?
Oh.
I don't know.
No, I didn't see it.
I'm just clicking.
I'm just head empty.
Oh, I think the dog is gonna throw up the key.
Yeah.
I guess there are worse things than chasing a dog through a cemetery.
It's a hunt.
Yeah.
He could be chasing us.
There we go.
We have to go around.
Oh, dog.
Puppy.
They should have more.
They should have dancing to the scene.
They really should.
Just make it a full, like...
Um...
Friday the 13th...
Style.
Yeah, yeah.
Why are they all...
Oh my gosh.
Don't fall in.
Ow!
Hey, dog.
Hey.
Oh, he's dead.
Ah!
I have a reoccurring nightmare.
And everyone in my family also has the same reoccurring nightmare.
What?
That I need to use the bathroom.
But the only bathroom is like a horrible, decrepit, horror movie bathroom.
It's like filthy and dirty.
Ah!
Oh, wow.
I never knew that a whole family could have recurring nightmares.
The curse.
The family curse.
So did that...
Bathroom kind of trigger something?
Like a...
I don't know.
It's always a different bathroom, you know?
Oh, this isn't out.
This is the theme.
Oh, this is the doll.
I think so, yeah.
It's blowing...
It's...
Oh, my gosh.
Get back here!
Oh, no!
Oh,
gosh.
Lots of zombies coming in.
Oh, he...
He ran...
He ran back this way.
Like, towards the cathedral.
He's just running everywhere.
Taking us on a wild dog chase.
Booty shot.
Ah!
Got him.
Wait, did he leave anything behind?
No.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Gotta make sure...
Good job, Leon.
Oh, my goodness.
Nice.
He kicked his head off.
He just got no brains.
No thoughts about it.
Head empty.
It's open.
Let's move.
Oh.
Why couldn't he...
He kicked so dramatically.
Oh!
Oh, my God!
Leon!
Where are you dying?
Oh, no!
Are you okay?
Why don't I go down there?
You never know.
Meet me at the cathedral.
They want us separated.
Okay.
Oh...
No!
A little help!
Are you asking for help?
Oh...
I'm just gonna run.
We're together.
I don't have very many of these bullets, so...
Where do I go?
Oh, good, I got some more bullets.
Oh, there's a cool door.
This looks like the snake temple.
Whoa, what?
Uh-oh.
Wait, where am I?
Okay, I think I go...
Ew, why are you crying?
Ew.
I might be in trouble.
Oh no, let me know!
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh, he's got his final scream.
Shut up.
Shut up, mister.
Give me your points.
What are you doing?
I'm killing zombies.
Actually, my side is pretty peaceful.
All things considered.
There's something over here.
I'm also killing zombies.
Got the big guy!
Yeah, I've got some big guys, too.
Oh, I'm hiding them.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, no!
What the hell was that?
Was that you?
I think I got hit with lightning.
I think so, too!
I think I'm down.
Are you down?
There was I think right before...
Okay, well we got separated.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, here I am.
There you are.
Oh.
Reload?
You never know.
Meet me at the cathedral.
The cathedral?
Oh, nice.
If I'm nice and close, it only takes one shot.
Are you doing all melee?
Is that what's happening?
No, no.
I've finally broken out the shotgun.
All right.
Proud of you.
Going out of your comfort zone.
Yeah.
I am.
I can't let the team down.
When I'm all on my lonesome.
Let me see your face.
Big guy.
He's not that big.
I guess.
Oh, I have no bullet.
He's kind of scared.
Please give bullet.
Oh, you give skill points.
Oh my god.
Horror game.
Horror game for real.
We're okay.
Oh.
Oh, stop.
Oh, I hear him.
I can hear him all the way from here.
Oh.
Finish him.
Oh, shoot.
Every time.
Every time they jump.
I hate the leapers.
Oh, shoot.
Why is he running so fast?
Oh god.
My aim is bad.
Oh, I got him though.
Somehow.
No.
He's like crying.
This guy.
I know.
The ones that are like... They're kind of big.
And he like runs away and cries.
Kind of relatable.
Are you okay?
From nowhere.
Yeah.
I'm going inside now.
Going in?
There was some sort of door.
No, no, no.
Oh, no.
I need backup.
Oh, wait.
I'm coming.
I think I go this way towards you.
Wait.
I think I'm close to you.
I hear you.
Oh, no.
Oh, my gosh.
There you are.
I see you.
I've come to you this whole time.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, it's okay.
Do you need some axe spray?
I do.
Wait.
I think I have some.
I just got to figure out how to use it.
Do you think there's herbs in the cemetery?
How do I give to her?
Oh!
You might not be able to.
If you can't.
If you don't see it.
No!
I think it usually pops up if you can.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I'll live until the next checkpoint at least.
Oh, yeah.
Here's the locked door.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I don't know where we're supposed to go.
There was another...
I think you follow where I was up here.
Okay.
Wait, I have...
Oh, my gosh.
I do have sprays.
I didn't realize that's how you use it.
Oh!
Oh, yay!
Oh, I have sprays.
Oh, my gosh.
Buddy.
Do I get to collect your loot, too?
Yeah.
I've been taking your stuff.
You can go around.
I fought a couple guys.
So, there should be some big, like...
Okay.
Big monies.
Big money.
Yeah.
I'm lost.
It's okay.
I'm with you.
I'll lead you back home.
Oh!
Hey, I totally cleared this area.
I think they keep respawning.
I think so, too.
They're tricky.
I think over here...
There was some more.
Unless...
Maybe, actually, you got it.
Oh.
Oh!
I watched him just walk out of there!
They do just walk out of there!
Yeah, they're spawning.
Oh!
Oh.
It's okay.
I'm coming.
I got him.
We're doing farm.
Skill point.
Infinitely.
That's true.
This is a great, like...
Farm.
You wanna lose your mind.
I think we go to the right here.
Yeah.
I haven't been up here yet.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, flirt?
You coming into this cathedral with me, or what?
Ooh!
They're so aggressive.
Just open the door.
I know!
Hurry!
Oh, we got a checkpoint.
Let's go.
There's a box!
Yeah, there's a box!
You got this?
And a grenade?
Yeah.
Grenade?
I could go for some health spray.
More box.
I will one day figure out...
How to use the grenade.
There's another grenade?
Stupid!
Laugh at him!
Oh, they just fall to the ground.
Guys, did you know that Nimi and I will have a cover come out soon-ish?
And at the beginning, Nimi does a really cute laugh.
Oh, thank you!
You're very cute in the whole song!
I'm so excited!
No, you're cute in the whole song!
You picked a good song.
I thought it would be so perfect for...
It felt like it fit us.
It was so fun.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh, I'm drinking my water!
Oh my god, I'm so sorry.
I'm using grenades!
Okay, use grenades.
That wasn't a grenade.
There we go.
Grenade, grenade!
Is he even doing anything?
Ah!
This grenade?
The church bell?
Are you kidding me?
Yeah, why is he bringing the church bell?
Why would you do this to us?
Mister?
Yeah.
Wee!
It's very Walking Dead.
Yeah!
Are we gonna get blown up by...
Hope is one!
Yeah, this guy.
This guy's icky.
Oh, shoot.
Please, reload faster!
See?
Oh, come on, I got pushed!
Yes!
Get his ass!
Oh god.
Where's that?
Oh my god!
What?
The sniper rifle?
I'm trying to grab this.
Oh no, no, please.
Reload.
How are you walking with no head?
Nice, that was pretty cool.
No, mine too.
They don't have to expose us at the end too.
You are...
You are on...
You are on controller though.
I have no excuse.
You're getting along the line, trust me now.
Hope is in for, yours is worth it.
It is.
I stake my life on it.
And my life too.
Yeah, right?
Oh,
are we supposed to go inside?
Oh!
Okay!
Hey!
Let us see you!
Are we in the pot now?
Ooh!
You did, you did that.
Oh, there's a lot of people here.
Oh, there's survivors!
Sorry guys.
We're not rescue workers.
We're just a normal dude and lady.
You see that guy with the big gun with no shoes on?
I didn't see he had no shoes.
He's just casual Friday.
He's gonna get a splinter like that.
He is.
I'm gonna go find him.
Hey, Mr. This guy?
Oh, he's got shoes on.
They just kind of blend in.
You're right.
Dude, just blend in.
Wait, can I have that?
Mr. Mr. Can I have that?
Trade you some shoes for it.
Oh wait, there's a lot to explore in here.
Yeah, there's herbs.
Are you smashing their supply crates?
Where are the herbs at?
There was one growing out of the floor.
Oh, wow.
Kind of a moldy...
I feel like Link.
I'm just destroying all their...
Yeah.
I just don't trust him.
Take care of him.
Are you okay, Mr.?
What are you looking a little zombie like right now?
Your movements.
Don't trust any of them.
Oh, I see a herb.
Oh no, wait.
I have to combine?
I have no space.
You make like a super herb?
A super herb!
You can.
Oh, I see.
Then I put it here.
No?
I still don't understand the herb combining.
Me neither.
Why can I not...
Go up and down?
They're all just yelling.
Did they let you attack people?
Oh.
No.
I don't think so.
I don't.
Oh, this guy?
Why are you squatting?
Who someone...
Does he deserve it?
Kill him.
Suspicious.
Kill...
Wow, what is he doing?
Hey.
Hey, mister.
Get up.
Don't double over in pain.
Oh my god, he's like dizzy.
Yeah.
He needs to sit down.
Oh wait, what's this?
Madonna of happiness.
Oh.
Oh, it's a puzzle.
There's more here than meets the eye.
Do we move the Madonna?
I don't know.
Where do...
Where does Madonna...
Oh, there's a...
Crazy statue.
Oh, it's gotta...
It's gotta move outwards.
Shit.
What do we do?
On these rails.
Let's take a look around.
Okay.
Maybe there's another Madonna?
Yeah, and then...
What?
Oh, you'll help me out.
Okay.
I'll boost you.
I noticed that there was...
That the ladder was broken.
Oh, there's like a Madonna spot here.
Oh.
No.
I placed Madonna.
Huh?
Something's happening.
What are we not seeing here?
Somebody's swearing.
The two...
The two motherly saints will reveal the path.
The two motherly saints will reveal...
Okay, so we gotta find another lady.
I'm searching.
Dang this...
Hmm?
Do I just stay down here?
Why does he never wanna join me?
Like you...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I think I can bring you here.
Hold on.
Oh, can you open a door?
Come in.
There you go.
Yeah.
What are you doing over there?
I'm destroying things.
Open the chest.
Open the chest, Mimi.
Is it a mimic?
It's a lady!
Madonna of Charity.
It's the other Madonna.
It's identical to the other one.
Something tells you...
Just for show.
What?
Oh, I think you put it here.
Two motherly saints will reveal the path.
Wait.
Oh, do I have it?
Are you okay?
I don't know.
I don't know what I'm doing.
There's no...
There's no prompt for me.
I'm just gonna stand here.
There it is.
Wait.
There's no prompt.
Wait, do I go to the other side?
Okay.
I think I go...
I'm like watching you.
My camera's on you.
It's gonna make me motion sick.
Wait, you're watching me right now?
Yeah, I am.
I think a really janky camera.
There.
Oh, nice.
Nice!
Oh.
Don't get squished in there.
It tried.
There's a little bit of an attempt.
Let's go.
The catacombs.
There can't be zombies in here.
Elena.
Grab the other one.
Okay.
Oh.
Are we gonna get separated?
Oh, no.
We are.
Why do they have this in the church?
They have laser beams!
Wait, it says defeat the statue.
What does that mean?
I don't know.
I pushed the button.
Oh.
What?
Uh-oh.
Oh.
Ouch!
I pressed E instead.
Okay.
Goodbye!
Who built this?
In the church?
For what reason?
This is aggressive.
Oh, I think there's gonna be more.
This is gonna get a little bit dicey.
Uh-oh.
And there's fire now even!
The theatrics.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's like a whack-a-mole.
It's the craziest game of whack-a-mole ever.
Oh, my gosh.
No, no, no, no.
Please!
This is gonna stop me.
Just keep moving.
Zig-zagging.
I'm serpentine.
Oh, my God!
Whack-a-mole!
Are you popping up?
I hear you.
Nope, that's your side.
Oh, my gosh!
There's two of them!
Two of them!
Ouch!
Oh, my God!
They're comboing me!
Me too!
No, no!
Why are there three of them?
Oh, my gosh.
This is getting crazy.
Serpentine.
That has to be it, right?
There can't be four of them.
Oh, no.
There's more.
Oh, my gosh.
Please, please, please, please, please.
Oh, there's way too many!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my gosh!
The tic-tac?
Is this like a...
cool church activity every...
Oh, we did it!
We did it!
Let's go.
I know, this is what they're doing, like the youth group.
What is this?
If I cross this, will I die?
What?
Oh, the... the previous guests have perished in the trials.
The Outlast trials.
Okay.
Were they grave robbing?
What is this?
Can you pick up the laser?
I think this is the laser from his gun.
I want that gun.
What?
Did it hurt you?
No.
Can you pick it up?
It doesn't let me do anything.
Oh.
It's another...
It's another puzzle.
I like it.
Wait, if I block it...
Oh, you're blocking it?
Oh, oh, we have lasers too.
Do you have a statue on your side?
Yeah.
Oh, that was it.
Okay.
Uh-oh.
Goodbye.
There can't be zombies here!
Why?
Wrong side.
I've got another statue.
Wait, do you have zombies?
Yeah, I have zombies.
You don't have zombies?
No.
I have one zombie.
One single zombie.
Oh, you have a...
Oh, I have a statue too.
I have a statue.
I got it.
Very good.
We're killing these puzzles.
We are.
It's like portal.
It really is.
Um...
Oh, wait.
Do I get the statue down here?
Wait, space.
Oh.
What does that mean?
No?
I don't think so.
It's already lit.
I think it's already lit.
Yeah.
Oh, up, up, up.
Up!
Mamers never look up.
It's true.
I say that all the time.
It's up again.
It's in like a mirror.
It's kind of cool.
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
You okay?
Oh, my God!
We just got one...
One singular zombie.
It's all...
Oh.
It's a mirror?
Yeah.
It's neat.
Oh.
And...
Oh, whoops.
That's not what I meant to press.
Oh, my gosh.
Madonna of Sorrow.
Did that just close something?
Are we in trouble?
Oh, it opened something.
Okay.
Very fancy.
I'm guessing that's how we leave after.
Yeah.
There were two more spots for statues, right?
Oh.
Wait.
I can't get this.
I'm full.
I can't get this ammo.
Because we don't have the gun.
Here it is.
Oh.
We got the sniper rifle!
Sniper!
Oh, and there's another statue.
Oh, but I think I'm actually full of this.
I can't actually take it.
Oh, shoot.
I put down a bomb.
By your feet.
That's okay.
Watch out.
Like, sniper.
Me too.
Um...
Are you gonna blow that up, or...?
I'll just leave.
Okay.
Don't worry about it.
Ominously...
Beeping.
Just don't accidentally press anything.
Oh!
Oh, it...
Oh, no.
It didn't explode.
That was just lightning.
Oh, wait.
I only have a little bit of ammo for this.
Yeah.
Wait.
Do we have to snipe something?
Maybe...
Oh, like the...
The statue.
The bell?
Where do you see the bell?
I don't know.
Oh, wait.
Toll the five bells loud and clear, and thus the true path shall appear.
Do we have to use the sniper?
I guess so.
I'm...
I'm cheap.
I know, right?
Oh, you don't need to use the sniper.
I...
That's three?
Four?
How many do we have?
I don't know.
Okay.
Wait, this is not gonna attract the zombies.
Is there a tiny one in there?
I think...
So...
I think I got it, maybe?
I believe.
Two more?
Oh, oh my goodness.
Oh, is that a bell?
Getting laggy.
Whoa.
No.
Oh, there's one there.
That's all.
Oh, nice.
I feel bad shooting your cheeks.
Bring all five bells.
Classic video game puzzles that don't make any sense.
I don't.
In the context of the world.
I just...
Yeah.
You just do it.
Search the cathedral.
Yeah, just do it.
Well, that door that I said would open up.
Opened up.
Shortcut.
Did you hear that?
I hope it was a door.
The bomb is still beeping.
Come on.
Nice.
We'll just leave that there.
Is everybody okay down there?
No, we're actually okay.
Boom.
I think we just killed everybody.
I'm not gonna lie.
Because we just like...
Why?
Oh, because of the bells.
Yeah.
That might be true.
Like all the zombies are gonna come in full force now.
What?
Oh, I'm pressing V?
Yeah.
Oh, so in sync.
I know.
Teamwork.
That's more like it.
Woohoo!
Oh, the zombies are all gonna come in flood and mass.
Maybe we can hide in there.
Oh, you're right.
There they are.
Ew.
It's wet.
Nothing good ever happens in these games.
No.
Oh!
Ew.
It's a juicy one.
Oh my god!
We really just put all these...
We just sealed these people in their tombs.
We did.
Don't touch them!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Wait, why don't we stay up there where it's safe?
Okay.
That's fine.
Oh, gosh.
I gotta reload.
I'm fast!
Ew!
It's laying on steam!
Oh my god, I'm down!
I'm down!
Are you okay?
Oh my god.
You're down?
I'm in trouble.
Okay, I'm coming.
I'm coming.
Don't die at me!
Oh!
No!
We
start right there, right?
Yeah, we should...
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, it's craziness!
Oh, there's actual zombies too!
I forgot.
There are.
Watch out!
Where's that thing come from?
Not the gas!
Does the gas spill the whole room?
I did the same thing.
Oh, he's just running around.
Oh, he's climbing!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh my...
Where are you going?
Where are you going, mister?
Oh, I can't get back up.
Ah!
When did you get turned, lady?
Don't panic, people!
Move away from it!
They're moving forward, then.
Everyone, out of the way!
They're so...
They're...
They're kinda stupid, I think.
Aw, man.
Are you okay over there?
Oh yeah, I'm just fighting...
Regular zombies.
I'm helping.
I'm...
Are you sniping?
Yeah.
Oh, I'm out of ammo.
How could you miss?
Oh my god!
You're busy lining up my shot.
Suddenly, everybody is a zombie.
It's a zombie.
It happened so fast.
People have died.
Everyone, run!
There's still one left!
I know!
Ah!
Who's shooting?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
I can kill you.
I need to reload, but I don't have very many bullets left.
Ah!
Oh.
I got five left with my sniper rifle.
Can I grab...
Did I grab it?
I wonder.
Is it down?
Oh gosh.
It's doing something.
I'm looting.
It's like...
But there's no one else to infect!
Everybody's dead!
Everyone died!
Oh, the herb grew back.
Not so many grenades, but I don't know how to use them yet, you guys.
There are?
Yeah, there's like two people over here.
Oh.
Actually, there's a ton of people upstairs.
Where did you guys come from?
Uh-oh.
No!
Ah!
Eh, why don't we get infected?
We have such claw armor.
It's so funny.
Oh, you guys are safe.
You're not dead yet.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll protect you all.
Ah!
Oh god!
It's coming towards me!
Oh, why did I need to reload?
Oh, he's climbing!
The worst time.
I'm on the ground.
For some reason.
Come on.
He's gonna kill the people!
I can't get off the ground.
Stop!
Nevermind, I didn't kill it.
It's like going a little insano mode right now.
Uh-oh.
Ah!
Got him!
He's coming down.
Again.
Oh, not towards me.
He's coming!
Oh no!
He can't grab anything.
No stinky!
Oh no!
Yes!
Okay, I lived.
Is there anyone left alive?
I'm just shooting anywhere.
That's nice.
To what?
I don't know.
Underground key card.
This thing was so gross!
I wasted all my ammo on it.
Yeah.
Wait, okay guys.
I need to learn how to use the grenades for real.
So I can pick up some of this ammo!
How do I use them?
How do you switch your regular weapons?
It's just the scroll wheel.
I just...
Do your other scroll wheel?
I can't...
Store my herbs?
Can I store more than 10 at a time?
Oh, whoops.
Oh, I can!
Okay, that works.
Okay.
I have so many grenades.
I have like 14 grenades.
Well, I could just throw them away.
Yeah.
I don't think it's arrow key.
Because that makes me move.
Like that.
Shift scroll?
Thank you!
Wait, so if I throw it...
Wait, how do I throw it?
I don't know.
Wait, okay, then I...
There we go.
Alright, I learned how to use it.
Oh, nice!
I learned!
Nothing can stop us now.
I'm gonna make it happen.
Are you ready?
Yep.
Let's go, baby!
I don't know why this guy had the key card.
I know.
Ready for what?
What?
You got this?
Another boss fight?
Money!
Money, money, baby!
Did you get the king piece?
The king piece?
Right here?
I think you got it.
So I don't...
I got skill points.
Do we share?
You have it.
I think, right?
Do we share?
We share?
I'm gonna have my grenades out.
We do share?
I don't know.
We don't share.
Skill points are shared.
I don't...
Oh, we do share.
Oh, lag.
Oh, no.
Is it a jump scare?
May or may not fall?
Are they loading the jump scare in?
No, there's just a man.
Just a man.
Oh!
Ow!
Okay!
I don't know who hit me.
The invisible man is beating me up.
Not the invisible man.
Hate that guy.
No good.
It's not gonna budge.
Now we're just in jail.
Oh, I see him in there.
Yeah.
Zombie jail.
You see him?
Yeah.
Wait, there's a little hole here.
Does this work?
Oops.
That is...
That's not...
If it's not gonna budge, where do we go?
Maybe if I grenade it.
Can we go through the grate?
I believe in grenades now.
Never mind.
I think this panel and the numbers in the doors are connected.
There's a puzzle!
Ah!
Uh-oh, you're gonna let him out.
Oh!
You're right, I am.
I was like, go back.
Go back.
We need two...
Something.
Yeah, what is it?
Oh, wait.
Huh?
I can't read it at all.
It's...
Wait...
Oh!
Well, it's either two...
Two...
Uh...
One zero, probably.
Yeah.
Oh, you're a genius.
I gamed!
It's not worth it.
I'm gonna grenade him.
Who?
I believe in grenades now, everybody.
A fifth grader could bust out of here.
You just have to punch in the numbers in the doors.
What door do we want?
Um, we want...
Oh, it's completely...
Blanked out.
We have no idea.
Well, it's not two ten.
And it's not...
It's not one...
I don't know.
Why are they all scratched out?
What if these would be left?
I think.
Um...
Wait...
Zero or two?
I say...
Um...
I know.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
I believe you.
Oops!
There might be a zombie in there.
Oh, there it is.
Almost had it.
You had it.
Wait, he's...
Who's keeping these lights on?
That's what I'm wondering about all of this.
Dang, he's transformed into a crazy zombie.
Why is there a scary, like, torture prison underneath the church?
Why is there a what?
Scary torture prison underneath the church?
I have a sneaking suspicion this is not a church.
What do you want, huh?
Oh!
Oh no!
Oopsie!
I probably could have guessed it wasn't that one.
Oh, it's this guy.
It has to be...
I killed him.
You killed him?
Oh!
Yeah, we're fine.
We're fine.
He's dead.
Good job.
He's done though.
Hey, we're getting to the skill points though.
But it's...
It's zero.
I believe!
Two, one.
You did it!
It's open, let's go!
Brute Force can solve anything!
It's true.
How I do every puzzle.
Biohazard!
It's the name of the game!
Yeah!
Oh!
The interrogation room?
The torture chamber.
I know!
Why did you bring me here?
Deborah must be close.
Deborah?
Who's Deborah and why do you remember the torture chamber?
I have many secrets.
You do!
Please be okay.
Could you share some with the rest of the class?
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's not looking so good for Deborah!
Nice!
Smash!
I did the mash!
I did the monster mash!
The monster mash!
It was a graveyard smash!
Oh!
Kill him!
Yeah!
Dodge!
How did I switch there?
There's like a...
Oh, I can press F as well!
Okay.
I'm learning the game.
Is this like a big revelation?
I don't know!
The music is so dramatic!
Yeah, right?
Oh, is this the lab where they invented the...
The virus or something?
Maybe in this place.
A bag of chips.
Chips?
Oh, nice!
They got some chips.
They're snacking down here.
And some french fries.
Ooh.
A PNG of french fries.
I don't think it's very good down here.
I don't think...
Debra made it.
That's cool.
That's so cool.
I know!
Debra, if you're here, give me a sign!
Oh, I found the urinals!
Oh no!
Oh!
God, I'm drawn.
Oh my god!
Oops.
I forgot to reload.
Kill that guy.
Nice.
I'm kicking him.
Kick his butt.
Oh, I keep...
Wait, R.
I keep pressing F on R or something.
Oh, that's us in the mirror!
Look at us!
Oh yeah!
Oh my gosh, you're a genius!
Oh, reload?
Yay!
Oh, I'm sorry.
What's with the panels, thanks to the urinals?
I don't really know much about urinals, to be honest.
Is this a standard feature?
What's it for?
It's those...
Yeah, they...
They probably...
Um...
Read...
And tell you if you're healthy or not.
Kind of...
Have you ever heard of those, like...
Litter boxes?
The kitty litter?
Yeah, the kitty litter!
That must be it.
That's handy.
Yeah.
Oh!
I got you.
I wish I could crawl through these vents.
They're like screaming to be crawled through.
They are!
Uh-oh.
Is that Debra?
I don't know.
Does she look like a Debra?
Dang.
I will.
It's just...
We're running out of time.
Please, Leon.
What do you mean?
We can talk and walk?
I know, right?
Like, we can...
What are we?
Savages?
We can...
Oh.
I'm the surgeon now.
It's terminal.
Um...
Oh, there's a door here!
I couldn't see it.
Whoa!
Anything else in here?
Wait, there's another door down here!
Wait, there...
Oh.
Okay, okay.
How do I leave?
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
I think this is a...
I think we want to explore here too.
Okay.
Oh.
That's creepy.
But the other door was showing as like the...
Yeah.
Interesting.
This is the optional boss fight.
No!
What the hell is all this?
None of these were here three days ago.
Three days ago?
That's how long it...
Is that for all of this?
That's it?
Crazy.
Be honest with me, Helena.
Did you invent these zombies?
Aww.
That sounds like a Helena thing to do.
Oh my gosh.
Birthday tapes are classic.
To Ada.
Oh, Ada.
Yeah.
These are classic in Resident Evil.
Is that Ada?
She's a...
I don't know.
She's been turned into the gold labubu.
Or is this like...
When your parents record over your childhood...
The HTS creeps.
With work stuff.
Then you feel crushed.
Oh no.
Oh, we saw this!
It's...
She was born!
Yeah, we did see this!
That's right!
Don't look too close.
Don't...
You can look, everybody.
Get a feast full.
Ada's actually an egg?
Egg-a.
Is that his girlfriend?
That was the...
Didn't we see that ring before?
Oh, yeah.
They have been showing us like a big old gold ring.
Yeah.
Is this what you wanted to show me?
No.
I thought...
So...
That's kind of messed up saying happy birthday.
What?
It is!
Then we will...
These will all give birth to Ada?
What the hell did I see?
Sounds like a win to me.
Yeah, honestly.
So that woman or whatever...
No.
We should let them live.
Yeah.
I'm the owner of the world's first golden Ada Wong.
Limited edition Ada Labubu.
Time to see...
What's behind door number 201?
Oh, come on.
Never mind.
Really?
No clues?
Another...
It's gotta be the urinals.
The panels on the walls.
We've gotta do this again.
Oh, oh, wait.
What...
What door was it?
What number?
Oh, uh, 201.
What'd you put?
I put zero.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is that the one?
That's her!
That she was born from?
Go get your girlfriend, Leon!
Milady!
Activate the pass...
Oh, you just...
Oh, I'm glad to be with her.
He's feisty.
He's...
Oh, there's a bunch of frozen ones down here.
I'm scared they're gonna come to life.
Oh.
Yeah.
Are they like, cicada shells?
Like, they're already empty, you know?
Oh.
Oh, yes!
There's a dog in there.
Oh.
He sounds angry.
No.
Wait.
There's here?
Oh.
I'm in the water.
Where did you go?
Oh, did you go down?
Yeah.
Oh.
I don't know if I like this.
I feel like this shouldn't be flooded.
There's nothing...
here?
Unless...
Can we crawl in here?
We should really be able to.
Right!
Activate the passageways.
Oh, there he is!
I feel bad for him.
Me too!
He's stuck!
Oh.
I'm hearing the dog.
Wait!
This guy is holding a gun!
Or he was...
trying to?
He's pointing the way.
Yeah.
Can we light him up?
Frankenstein's monster?
Whoa!
Okay.
Oh, no.
Puzzle.
Oh!
I'm...
I'll pull it!
Okay!
We have to activate it one by one.
Oh.
Why does everything have to be complicated?
That's what I'm asking.
Is the order important?
Well, how do we...
Oh.
How do we even get to the other ones?
I don't know.
Whoa...
Oh!
Where did you come from?
I know!
Oh!
Just bullying these guys.
So...
Oh, these little tippy-taps are so...
Oh, they're...
Okay.
Oh, they're coming through the vents!
You okay?
I'm okay.
Okay.
Come on, Helena.
We gotta activate this thing.
Okay.
Oh.
Are you okay?
Why is he back seating while he's being down by zombies?
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
He's like on the ground.
Come on, Helena.
Oh my gosh.
How did that...
Wait, they're just like flopping out.
This is crazy.
Oh!
I know!
I have the high ground.
It's over.
Oh, come on.
You gotta activate this thing.
Now it's you.
Okay.
Maybe it's just linear after all.
Maybe...
Can we just go?
Oh my god.
Nice.
You guys gotta drop anything.
Come on, don't be stingy.
Yeah.
Give us some runes, precious.
Thank you, Smeagol.
Oh wait, I think we dropped down here.
Oh, oh.
Trying to help.
Got him.
Nice.
Oh no!
Goal shipping it.
That was awesome.
Yeah!
Have you been getting your daily login bonus?
For goal ship week?
Yes!
Yeah!
Really
good trainer.
Yeah.
I just really went up.
No, I think we're supposed to go...
Oh my gosh!
Oh my god!
Did I do that?
What's
happening?
We're going up?
We're still moving around.
Yeah, I think we go up and then we go to...
Yeah, the elevator opened up.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Ow!
What the...
Did you just die?
I died!
No!
Don't make us free to the whole area, please!
Oh...
Well, we know what to do now.
It should be fast.
What the hell did I just see, Ada?
No...
Oh...
It's okay!
It's now 201.
No!
We are all the way back here!
Yeah...
It's okay.
This again?
Oh no...
Two...
One...
We know what to do!
We're okay!
Let's go!
We'll speedrun it!
Yeah, we can speedrun.
So just go...
Um...
I think it was...
The first one was...
Wait, what do we...
Right here?
Yeah, yeah.
That one was first.
Okay.
And then when you pull it...
I'll get this one over here.
Okay.
Unless it doesn't let you.
Unless it's like...
Oh, there we go.
Nice!
Oh!
Oh, golly.
Okay.
I'm okay.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gosh.
We're killing guys.
We're okay?
Oh, she looked at me!
Ew!
She like...
That was so creepy!
Oh my god!
Whoa.
Okay.
Now we go back down.
Yes.
Can we swim?
We swim.
Wait, though.
Wait, is this right?
Yeah.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Yeah, yeah.
This is right.
Just run!
Go for it.
I think we're gonna have to come down here again...
Eventually, but...
For now, it's...
Oh!
You got me!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh.
Why do I keep pressing F instead?
I have R.
My fingers are too small.
Can't reach.
You need one of those mini keyboards.
Are you okay?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh!
Thank you.
Now it's my turn.
Wait.
We just keep getting...
No ice.
Okay.
But we're caught up now, right?
Yeah, we're caught up.
Oh, actually...
Where do we go?
Oh!
Just to the other side.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh.
I'll give you a boost.
Wait, am I?
Oh, I am.
Oh!
Right to a zombie!
Oh, you got the other one?
You gotta activate this thing.
Oh!
Shoot!
Oh, ow.
Trying to get down.
How did he live?
Please.
What?
Oh, no, no, no!
No, no, no!
You have one too?
I don't know.
I don't know where he is.
Oh my gosh.
Ow.
I need a...
He's on me.
Did I just start?
Are you kidding me?
Oh my gosh.
Where did you come from?
What?
Am I dead?
Please no.
Oh no.
It's on you with all the hard monsters.
Did we get a save at least?
I don't know.
Please.
Please give me kind.
That wasn't fair.
I know, right?
That was crazy.
What the hell did I just see?
No.
So that woman...
It's sadistic.
What was this again?
What's the...
What's the room?
Two...
One.
Is this the same?
I guess it would be, yeah.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Oh, whoops.
I must be able to get to you...
There.
I don't know.
Maybe you could snipe him.
Yeah, I was trying to snipe him.
And failing.
Wait, I'm gonna kill this...
I'll try harder.
I'm gonna kill this guy preemptively.
Wait, can I?
Can I kill him?
I don't think so.
Alright.
Once you make your move...
Perfect.
Perfect speed running.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, maybe he is...
Already dead.
Speed running.
Oh wait, I'm by myself!
Oh, why did I do that?
Um...
Uh...
We're okay.
Sorry,
I made a mistake.
That's okay.
I didn't...
Wait, it's actually perfect speed running.
Yeah, we're actually speed running.
This is actually great.
I just run to the other side.
We juke him?
Uh oh.
Nice.
Okay.
Tippy toppy dog.
Oh goodness.
It's...
It's never ending.
I know.
Oh gosh, I'm out of...
Hide the bat!
That was good.
That was fast.
For now.
Ooh.
Skill point.
And now...
Comes the scary part.
I know, I'm scared.
I'm scared for real.
Wait, what was that?
Oh my gosh.
That's just me.
Okay, come over here.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Let me prepare my weapon.
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Oh.
Ah!
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh my god!
Nice!
What's happening?
Okay, we got them.
Wait, I did not prepare my weapon.
Oh.
Shut up, lady.
Shut up.
Okay.
Not sniper.
Oh my gosh!
I wish I could use this.
Okay.
Maybe I use this.
Um...
Are you okay?
Yes.
Hurry, Leon.
You gotta activate this thing.
Uh...
I'm the one taking the long time.
Okay.
It's me.
It's not you.
Wait.
No.
Am I gonna...
Help!
Can I tow it to you?
I'm just unloading on him.
I'm unloading on him.
I did it!
Yeah!
From the other side.
Oh.
There's...
There's nothing behind me.
There's so many.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Oh!
I'm running.
I'm scared.
Don't be scared.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna throw a grenade.
No!
Yeah!
Nice!
Hit it!
Oh!
Uh...
Are you gonna die yet, lady?
Or...
Wait.
I kinda want your stuff though!
Oh!
Wait.
How do I get outta here?
How do I...
Hurry it up!
Oh, okay.
I found it.
Okay.
That went better!
Yeah!
That was way smoother than before.
What happened last time?
When I get to take your loot.
Yeah, take it, take it.
Get them skill points.
Wait.
I can't pick this up.
Oh, yes I can!
And skill points!
And loot!
Loot, loot, loot!
Loot and skill points!
Skill points!
Maybe...
I think if we open this, hopefully it's a checkpoint, so...
It better be.
Hopefully!
Please, game!
We've earned it!
Surely!
Well, they're gonna give us another boss.
No.
Take point!
Yippee!
Woah.
This is scary.
Oh!
I thought that was an alive person.
Why would that be an alive person?
I love how they drop ammo.
I know!
Even when it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make sense, but it...
It just works.
Scientist was killing...
Oh, it's this guy.
Oh!
Oh, my game is lagging!
Uh oh!
I'm okay!
Ow!
My game is lagging so bad!
Yeah, shut up!
Shut up!
Stupid!
Oh!
Ouchie!
Thank you!
Nice!
Oh!
Ow!
Oh my gosh!
They all started coming out of nowhere!
Oh, they...
They could overwhelm us.
Indeed.
Okay.
You're here?
Through the chute?
Okay!
Hold on, I'm grabbing some guns.
I'm grabbing some...
Okay.
I can watch you.
Grab...
Okay, okay!
Oh!
Found the garbage!
Shoot!
This always seems like a horrible idea.
I know!
What if we just drop into a pit of them?
Like...
Yeah!
Or like a crusher where the...
The walls are slowly coming in.
Oh!
That's so Indiana Jones.
Wait.
This feels...
Now we're like in a cave.
I know!
What is...
What's happening?
Find Debra.
We're...
Oh, we're still looking for her?
Yeah?
Why can't you fill me in yet?
Yeah.
Because you probably wouldn't believe me.
That's why I want to show you.
I think I would believe anything in this thing.
I think there's alligators down here.
Oh!
I hope so!
I've been waiting for alligators.
Nice!
View!
Cool!
Wow!
We're suddenly at RE7.
Yeah, Ryan.
Is she jealous?
Ooh!
Helena jealous?
Ancient pottery?
Yeah, who cares about the...
Priceless ancient pottery?
I don't care about no pottery.
Are you good?
I just need a little...
A little boost.
A little spritz.
A little pick me up.
Yeah.
A little dry shampoo.
Oh!
You good?
Oh, yeah.
Where are you?
Why would Debra be down here?
I don't know.
It's like your girl's dead, bro.
She's a good one.
Thanks!
Is that her?
Debra has no pants on!
She's kind of cute!
Yeah, why is she wearing the little 90s, little baby doll?
This is definitely a boss arena.
Debra!
What's she wearing?
This is what she wanted to show us.
Yeah!
She was like, you'd never believe me if I told you that Debra only walks around in her underwear.
I wanted to show you instead.
Thank you for showing me.
Okay.
Enough with the mystery.
What the hell is going on here?
Let's just get her out of here.
Oh my gosh, Helena, please!
Please, Helena!
You're driving me crazy.
Oh no.
I know!
Is this an escort mission?
Oh no, it probably is.
You have to carry her!
Ha ha!
No!
Oh, okay.
We leave the hostiles to you.
Oh!
Wait, wait.
I can't shoot or do anything, actually.
You can't?
No!
Are we going...
Where are we going?
I can do...
Do you guys see the cheeks?
Wow!
Wait!
Show me, show me!
Oh!
We're going...
Down?
Wait, where are you going?
Classic.
The only way out now is down.
Okay.
Oh, that's where we came from, right?
Wait, where'd you go?
I'm right here.
I've already failed my escort mission.
I think I hear Zombos down here.
I'll fight them.
Or I hear Debra.
Debra's kinda loud.
I'm not gonna lie.
Really?
Yeah, she's like moaning and groaning.
I can't hear it all.
Oh!
Leave it to you!
I've got it.
You like tripped.
Nice.
Nah, I really can't do anything.
This kinda sucks.
Sorry.
What are you supposed to do in single player mode?
Probably your partner.
You still get a partner, right?
Oh, true, true.
AI.
Yeah, we should be able to swing Debra around like a weapon.
You should!
Just grab her by your ankles.
Yeah, that would be awesome.
Swing!
I don't know.
I get the feeling that Debra is evil.
Or at least she has some, like, part in this.
Oh, watch out!
Oh!
You're just stuck in the window!
Watch out!
You got him.
I never doubted.
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Watch out!
The roof is caving in!
What's happening?
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm all right.
Oh, watch out, watch out.
Yeah!
Double!
Yeah, nice.
Ooh, it's getting real shaky in here.
Yeah.
You think this rope bridge will hold?
Nope.
I can't with the shaky camera.
It's making me a little sick.
I know!
In the pre...
The pre-logue?
Pro-logue?
Uh-huh.
It was especially bad when the helicopter crashed.
Yeah!
Remember that?
Yeah, I do.
Sorry that we didn't play it on stream, guys, but...
Yeah.
You didn't miss too much.
No.
We just got through the...
So we could activate the...
What's it called?
The...
Co-op?
Yeah, the co-op.
Are you alive?
Yep!
I'm right behind you.
I'm gathering all the things.
Can I help at least with this?
No, I can't do anything!
Don't worry, m'lady.
I will handle it for you.
Yeah, I'm getting the real princess treatment right now.
Debra's getting the real princess treatment.
Come on, Debra.
Wake up!
Pull your weight!
Why would she just like...
She's on a table.
Lounge.
Oh!
Okay.
Good job.
Are you good?
Yep.
I'm okay.
There's another one on the bridge though.
Oh, okay.
He's a little slow.
He's like actually really slow.
Oh!
He spits.
He's spitting though.
He's got bars.
Sure does.
Onward.
Wait, is this the right way?
Yep.
Oh yeah, down here.
I mean, this looks like a boss arena.
I can't stop looking at her.
Her butt keeps boggling around.
I gotta check out your POV.
Debra has a bakery.
It's like...
Oh!
Debra.
Just hold on.
We're almost there.
Debra, stay with me, alright?
Uh oh.
Debra!
Oh, Debra!
Oh my god!
She turned into one of the gold people!
So Ada was born like this?
Oh!
And now Debra is born.
Is she gonna be cute?
Maybe if you were born cute, you will have to be reborn ugly.
Oh.
She's still reaching out for her.
Ada!
Oh my god!
Oh, she's so cool!
With her crossbow!
I know.
Ada.
The true waifu is here.
Stares at the camera.
A ghost.
Up.
What?
Put your gut down!
Who are...
Excuse me, ma'am.
Disrespect!
Yeah!
She saved you!
Ada.
What the hell is going on here?
It's complicated.
Were you creating in a lab, Ada?
Ada?
Are you born from an egg?
But this isn't the time, or the place.
Now we gotta get out of here.
She's cool!
These walkways won't hold.
We need to get to the lower levels.
Oh.
So sorry, Debra.
Wait!
Oh!
So bad.
No, yeah!
She actually looks kinda normal.
Uh-oh.
I spoke too soon!
We might have been able to let her cook a little longer.
You know?
Oh shoot!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, am I not gonna be Helena anymore?
Oh wait, I have to get out of this.
Actually, it's kinda messed up.
I don't know how to help you!
Wow, this is crazy!
This is crazy!
Can I show this on stream?
Wait.
Is it all me?
No way.
Are we separated again?
Yeah.
But you have Ada.
Debra!
It should've been me!
Hey, you got to see Debra's bakery.
But that...
I had a really...
I had a...
I had a show.
Oh, that guy just dropped and...
Oh!
Whoa!
Ada!
It's crazy!
What's happening?
I just see her swing from my feet!
Oh my god!
That'll make sense later.
Wait.
Okay.
You think all of the stories intersect then?
I guess so, right?
Wait.
What's...
Why can't I...
Oh, there we go.
I'm just shooting zombies.
Boring!
I'm right below you now.
Yeah, I'm being a little slow.
Cause I'm trying to get stuff.
Nothing.
Stingy.
Oh.
I don't know where that is.
Um...
Oh, Debra.
Can I go down?
Oh, can you pull that lever?
Yep.
Yay!
Oh.
Are we gonna swing again?
I wanna watch.
Let go, Ada!
Wee!
Hi!
I got Debra!
Run!
Ah!
Oh my god!
Watch out, you two.
She's strong.
Watch out for yourself.
Holy moly!
Where?
I can't put this on...
Show this on TV.
Oh my gosh!
Oh!
Is that...
Was that it?
Down
there so fast!
You!
You need to get over her.
I know.
Oh, wait.
Time for a different...
Oh, she's...
She reminds me of a frog.
You should put her down.
That's very cute.
I like frogs.
Wait.
That's a buggy hero.
This is a nightmare.
Yeah.
It can't be real!
Try
to be a scorpion.
Yeah.
Got that froggy snabbiness.
That's true.
Mm-mm.
I see...
Yeah.
Scorpion too.
Oh, Debra.
I feel like if we let her incubate a little longer...
Maybe she would've come out like Ada.
Yeah!
Ada's fine.
What happened to you?
Wait.
Is this TNT?
I think that's Dying Way.
Are we supposed to blow her up?
I think so.
Oh!
She came right at me.
You okay?
Yep.
Wait.
Give me them skill points.
Oh, there's zombies coming down too.
Chomping?
Chomping on the guy?
Yeah.
She's breakdancing.
I like when she does that.
Ah!
I like when she jumps and pins me down.
She's like a flower.
A beautiful flower.
A beautiful flower, Debra.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
I'm trying to get her out over here by the TNT.
Oh, gosh, she got me again.
Uh oh.
It's okay.
I ate my pills.
Breakdancing, Debra.
Is she crying?
Nah, she's like...
I think she's being sexy.
Yeah.
I would say so.
Oh.
Oh, we got her!
Helena!
Oh, we're fine.
Oh, we didn't get her.
I think.
Oh, now are you with Ada?
Yeah.
Oh.
Sorry.
You're gonna get to swing.
I stole your girl.
I don't know if I'm swinging.
Oh, my gosh.
She jumped right on top of me.
Oh.
Ada!
Helena!
A little help here?
What?
The more things change, the more things change.
Oh, am I supposed to help you?
Like, okay.
I don't know.
Oh.
I think so.
I'm just running.
Okay.
Um, I'll get my sniper out.
Oh, sorry.
Ada.
Don't mean the disrespect.
Oh.
Are you supposed to jump?
Where you guys...
You guys are going down.
I don't know what we're doing.
I think I'm supposed to help, like, clear the path for you.
But it's...
It's really difficult.
It's okay.
I'll just run past them.
Oh.
I wasn't even reloading.
Yeah.
Just run past.
Ada's doing a fine job, honestly.
She's carrying.
I'm not gonna waste my ammo on those guys.
I mean...
This
guy wearing, like, medieval armor.
Where are we?
Where are...
Yeah.
When are...
Now I wanna be sexy, Deborah.
Wait, you're still going down?
Yeah.
Um...
I don't know.
I don't know when it stops.
He's trying to chase you.
Oh, it stopped.
It's still shaky, though.
It's really shaky.
How do I get out?
Ada, how do we get out?
Ada.
Like an ancient temple.
How do we...
Let me let you out.
Oh, you let me out.
Okay.
Oh, hello.
Ladies.
Your Uber is here.
What is she shooting at?
I'm coming.
Hello.
Let's hope this is non-stop right out of here.
What just happened?
We gotta dodge.
Oh, what are we dodging?
Oh my god.
Stay down.
We need to just stay down.
Oh, for real.
Just stop.
We
need to dodge while fighting her.
It's too much.
No, no way.
Debra, this isn't you.
It doesn't have to be like this, Debra.
Oh, we can run her over.
Oh, Debra.
Debra doesn't care if she's run over or not.
She's not coming over that time.
She's trying to kill you.
Don't you think I know that?
Oh, gosh.
I don't know what I'm supposed to be hitting her.
Little spawns or...
Are they hitting her glowy spots?
Yeah, the glowy spots.
I've been trying to hit her, but the glowy spots makes more sense.
Oh, shoot.
Ada's fine though.
She doesn't need anything.
Smack me.
Oh, you're giving me smelling sauce.
I am.
I mean, not Ada, Debra.
Too many...
Too many women.
Wait, this seems so fun.
It's like Donkey Kong.
Oh, dodge.
Ada is probably like these idiots.
Oh my god.
Why can't I stay down?
I know.
Just stay down.
It's not worth it.
At least we reached the checkpoint.
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh
my god.
Oh, it's so much harder.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Uh oh.
I get hit into a cutscene every time.
Save us, cutscene.
Save us.
Oh, she better not die.
Oh my god.
Ada can't die.
Nah, I don't think Ada will die.
Oh.
Debra!
Debra, this isn't like you.
Oh, I gotta reload.
Never mind.
What do I do?
Oh, Debra!
I was trying to shoot...
I wish.
She's got physics and everything.
I know.
Wait, did I let Ada die?
I might have.
No, she's fine.
She's fine, she's fine.
No more tears.
Not until I avenge your death.
Aw, she's too slippery.
She's like a frog, covered in slime.
I don't think this is the last of her, I feel.
She feels like a final boss, you know?
I know, yeah.
Because if you don't see the death happen, they don't die.
That's true.
Who?
I think we'll see her.
Who's him?
Yeah, who's him?
Guy with the ring?
Look at me.
Look at me, it's gonna be okay.
Just keep your eyes on me.
Help me.
I'm gonna get you out of here, Debra.
Debra, look at me.
We're gonna get through this.
Him!
It's the green goblin!
The green devil!
She really could've told us this.
I know!
I feel like.
What were we supposed to see that we wouldn't believe?
Yeah!
I didn't know what else to do.
So I helped him.
I helped Simmons breach the president's security.
Oh, Simmons.
That sounds like Simmons, alright.
Everybody knows Simmons except me?
Why the hell would we do all this?
Well, apparently we do know him.
Long story.
We're up against the people who really run this country.
in a very dangerous game.
And if you don't play your hand right...
She's so cool.
I know.
She reminds me of a vampire.
She's like a perpetual smirker.
She's always got a smirk.
Yeah.
Simmons there.
Hunnigan, you need to be careful.
I think he's the one who did all that.
We're just FaceTiming him?
Simmons.
All I can think of is Gene Simmons.
Gonna give us a workout.
Oh wow, we actually did.
That didn't take very long.
Yeah, that didn't.
Yeah.
Yahoo!
Oh, you got A again.
Good job.
Thank you.
But you got so many more enemies than me.
Not really.
And your accuracy.
Good job, team.
That's just because I use a knife.
It's only 2% different.
This is good.
Wait, that's Richard Simmons.
Wait, Gene Simmons is from Kiss.
Yeah, that's who I thought you were talking about.
Oh, I was thinking of Richard Simmons.
Who's Richard Simmons?
Richard Simmons is the one who does the 80's workout videos.
One time I saw Gene Simmons at a convention and I took a picture of him.
And then the people were like, um, you need to pay for that photo, young lady.
And I was like, oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
Did you think he was like a cosplayer?
He had a sign, you know, that was like, this is Gene Simmons.
Hi, I'm Gene Simmons.
I think I've heard that guy.
Which I guess you shouldn't take pictures without permission, but I didn't know.
I didn't know.
A wild Gene Simmons.
Yeah.
Do you want to end it here?
I think this is a good spot to stop.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah.
There was a timer.
Can we spend our money though?
Oh yeah, let's spend our money.
Yeah.
Oh, damn.
I want...
cash money.
Oh wait, I can only...
I still...
I want more money.
I think I'll save up for defense.
I kind of want to save too.
Maybe I should get defense level one though.
Oh.
Defense level two is pricey.
It does save, right?
Yeah, it is.
All the level twos are pricey.
Yeah.
I actually had fun with this game.
People say it's bad, but I feel like it's pretty fun.
I think it's...
It's pretty silly.
Yeah, I think that's why they think it's bad.
Because they're like...
Yeah.
I expect a serious Leon Kennedy and instead we're getting janked.
It's...
It's no like...
Well, it's not really comparable to Resident Evil 7.
For what I've played, but...
I think this is a great introduction though.
Even though I don't know any of these people or anything that's happening.
Yeah.
I'm really enjoying myself.
You should...
You should play...
You should play seven.
And I should play the others too.
My friend told me to start at four.
So I think I'll start this.
Yeah.
Hmm.
That's probably smart.
Aww.
But this was so fun!
This was fun!
Yeah.
I'm down to beat this campaign.
Me too!
I'm kinda curious how it...
How it ends.
If it's only four chapters...
Wait, I thought it was five.
No, we're like...
Oh wait, five chapters.
Hmm.
Okay.
Then we will play this again!
We will return.
Leon and Helena.
And Ada.
Ada, my beloved.
Oh, she's...
Ada the vampire.
She has vampire vibes.
Do you like Vincent from Final Fantasy?
Um, I don't know Final Fantasy.
But I'm sure I would like him.
I think you'd like him.
Actually, there's a guy named Vamp in Metal Gear.
Is he a vampire?
No, he's bisexual.
Well, you could be both, you know?
Sometimes the best vampires are.
No, that's a fact that's brought up in-game.
I see him.
I'm Googling.
Oh!
He's got a long tongue.
Yeah, I do.
Yeah.
Thank you for playing.
Everybody subscribe to Min's channel.
For a surprise.
For a surprise, yeah.
Whatever could it be?
But yeah, thank you, Timmy.
Thank you for playing with me.
This is so fun so far.
Thank you so much.
I know, it's pretty fun.
It's silly.
Yeah.
I thought, like, I was like, oh, maybe it'll be kind of like...
Like, I still wanted to play, but I was like, it was Resident Evil.
We were kind of like, maybe gonna do a silly horror game.
But in the end...
It turned out pretty silly anyway.
Yeah, it was so great.
And thank you all for watching and hanging out with us.
Yes.
Yes, thank you for watching.
Yeah.
Subscribe to Mint.
Subscribe to...
I'm sure everybody here is already subscribed to you.
Subscribe to both of us.
For a surprise.
But I guess I'll see you later.
Yeah, I'll see you later.
I wanna...
Hold on, I wanna make sure...
If I exit out of this...
Wait.
Will we...
Yeah...
Escape?
Oh.
I'm sure it's saved.
Probably, right?
Yes.
It's just a countdown for one minute.
It's kind of ominous.
It is ominous.
It should...
Host should save?
Okay, okay.
I think we're gonna be good.
I'm sure it's good.
Okay.
Well then, I'll see you later.
Bye-bye.
Are you gonna talk to your child?
Are you?
I was gonna say hello...
To them.
Okay, I'll say hello...
Okay.
Okay, thank you, Mint.
Thank you, dude.
I'll see you later.
Yeah, I'll see you later.
Bye-bye.
When you close out of the...
Or when you click out of the game...
It...
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna quit.
Once it...
Counts down.
What if it's a cutscene, though?
Oh, no!
The president spoke highly of you, Agent Kennedy.
Oh, what do we do?
I told you we've been friends for 30 years.
Tell me...
I should replay, though.
Right?
What are you saying?
Are we just gonna watch it?
Alt F4.
You must be aware that you are both...
Suspects...
Suspects?
What?
Agent Harper...
I can't believe I said the Green Devil.
What's wrong with me?
Leaving the president vulnerable.
Okay, I'm gonna Alt F4.
You must admit such behavior is...
Oh, it disappeared.
For real.
I can't believe I called him the Green Devil.
What's wrong with me?
It's so embarrassing.
Nimi disappeared.
It's just me.
Oh.
Yeah, it's just me.
Oh!
Why am I gone?
There we go.
My arms were tired.
I wanted to put them up.
Why are my arms tired?
Lilac cameo.
But thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you.
This was so much fun.
And...
Yeah, I'm really hungry.
So I'm actually gonna go eat dinner.
I'm so, so hungry.
But I didn't want to say anything because I was having so much fun.
But thank you all.
And I'll see you guys when I see you.
And...
Yeah!
I do love when my Oshi does things with my Oshi.
Yippee!
I love Nimi Nightmare.
She's so cute.
And so fun to hang out with.
We were such a great team.
I was really having so much fun with her.
Akidoki!
I will see you guys...
Later!
Otsubito!
Eat the last time!
Thank you guys!
Sorry.
I would stay for longer, but I'm so, so hungry.
I'll see you.
Bye bye!
Bye!